Wir wollen sprechen über den europäischen Top-Fußball. Heute blicken wir auf die Ligue 1 mit Jakob Haffke, auf die Premier League mit Uli Hebel, auf die La Liga– das war jetzt grammatikalisch falsch– mit Alex Truica und auf die Serie A mit Christian Bernhard. Und jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich begrüße hier meine Viererrunde bei mir. Guten Morgen, die Herren.
Guten Morgen.
Ah, guck mal an.
Ich habe gelernt.
Ligatour 200 klappt dann irgendwann auch mal. Sehr, sehr schön. Schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Lasst uns auch gleich reinspringen in unsere Themen. Uli, wenn du magst, dann lass du mal beginnen. Wir freuen uns so sehr, dich in dieser Schärfe zu sehen. Das ist jetzt ein kleiner Insider für den Rest von uns. Lass uns mal zuerst auf die Premier League blicken. Und ich habe dir vorgeschlagen, dass wir mal über einen Trainer sprechen, den wir schon länger nicht mehr hier in der Sendung hatten, obwohl es einen deutschen Bezug gibt. Fabian Hürzeler und Brighton in Half Albion.
Wie läuft es denn da eigentlich so?
Semi, das ist ganz interessant. Wir haben das bei unserem Podcast tatsächlich auch nämlich auf Halde gelegt, weil wir das jetzt mal etwas tiefer beleuchten müssen. Es ziehen gerade komische Fronten auf, gegen ihn auch. Es gibt mindestens, glaube ich, die Hälfte aller Supporter bei Brighton, die die Ablösung fordern, spätestens dann zum Saisonende, viele aber sogar sofort, weil sich gewisse Dinge einfach nicht geändert haben jetzt in den fast zwei Jahren, die es ja dann demnächst sind. Vor allen Dingen namentlich Spielmanagement, also dass sie hinten raus Spiele abgeben, Gegentore kassieren, ganz häufig in der Nachspielzeit oder letzte Viertelstunde, letzte halbe Stunde, da werden sie so komisch fahrig, was, also Spoiler daran liegt, dass die Mannschaft einfach wahnsinnig jung ist. So nichts aber, was Hürzeler so richtig gelten lässt. Also das sagt er auch immer wieder. Aber dann kann ich mit ihm telefonieren im Vorfeld von Spielen. Da äußert er sich auch ähnlich und ich glaube, er meint auch immer so ein Stück sich selbst damit, wenn er sowas sagt, dass das Alter nicht entscheidend sein darf über Reife oder nicht Reife. Das ist aber weiterhin ein Problem. So richtig seit November ungefähr laut meinen Aufzeichnungen war jetzt kein Spiel mehr dabei, wo ich sage, das war richtig gut. Nichtsdestotrotz ist aber die taktische Struktur aus meiner Sicht eigentlich immer die richtige. Das heißt, es liegt daran, dass die Spieler den Plan nicht richtig umsetzen können, was auch mit einer gewissen Fluktuation zu tun hat, zum Teil auch so zu erklären ist. Ich versuche schon relativ schnell auf ein paar Punkte zu kommen. Sie haben keinen richtigen Stürmer drin, außer Danny Welbeck. Zimas, als der langsam ankam in der Liga, hat sich dann verletzt, ist raus, bis Saisonende auf jeden Fall. Kostulas war jemand, der– also beide Zimas Kostulas, junge Stürmer, die nicht im Ansatz auf Premier League-Level waren, auch körperlich nicht. Hürzeler hat das auch so erklärt, dass er gesagt hat, die können gar nicht im Dreitagesrhythmus diese Intensität gehen. Als dann Zimas endlich so weit war, verletzt er sich. Ich vermute auch, ohne das medizinische Wissen zu haben, das mag zusammenhängen. Welbeck ist grundsätzlich gut, war auch so, wie er in die Saison gestartet ist, ein Kandidat für die WM, sogar wieder für England. Nur das Problem bei Danny Welbeck ist halt einfach, der Körper ist nicht hundertprozentig belastbar. Und so hängt es oft an Jorginho Rütter, der dann plötzlich hätte zum Torschützen werden müssen. Und das hat halt vorne und hinten nicht funktioniert. Der Output bei ihm ist einfach schlicht nicht da. Und da geht es los, dass sie da manchmal quasi gute Dinge erspielen, die Chancen aber nicht nutzen. Und wenn das passiert, wirkt sich es wiederum auf Selbstvertrauen aus. Dann fangen sie manchmal so, es ist einfach ein Team, das ist natürlich so gebaut, dass ganz häufig Spiele 50-50 laufen sollten, idealerweise, wenn sie nicht laufen. Oder wenn sie hinten raus dann noch mal Tore kassieren, dann wird es ungut. Und so langsam aber sicher wird es zum ersten Mal seit Jahren sowas wie Frust breit bei Brighton. Und es entlädt sich ziemlich klar an Hürzeler. Muss man schon sagen.
Und wie würdest du sagen, wie gerechtfertig ist das? Weil da sind jetzt natürlich ein paar Punkte dabei, die könnte man auf ihn zurückführen. Ein paar scheinen aber ja auch so im Kader angelegt zu sein, wo er natürlich Mitsprachrecht hat, aber ist ja nicht seine alleinige Verantwortung.
Also ich würde ihm eigentlich gar keine Schuld, das ist groß, aber aus meiner Sicht ist immer, alles was ich sehe, ist sinnvoll, was er tut. Und er würde den ja nicht sagen, Jungs, letzte Viertelstunde lass gut sein. Sondern ich würde tippen, dass es einfach liegt an der Zusammenstellung des Kaders. Man sieht auch nochmal, das ist vielleicht ein ganz gutes Beispiel, an den Symptomen des Deadline Days sieht man nochmal, wie wenig, die sind ratlos ein bisschen. Weil Brighton Gruda ist jemand, den hat sich Fabian Hürzeler gegönnt. Der kam mit, den wollte er unbedingt haben. Das ist ein Spieler, von dem er immer wieder gesagt hat, das ist mein Mann, das ist mein Mann, das ist mein Mann. Er hat ihn immer wieder gebracht. Der kam mit einer schwierigen Verletzung da an. Es hat eine Weile gedauert, ehe er reinkam. So richtig abgehoben hat es nicht bis dato. Aber, dass sie ihn jetzt auf einmal überraschend nach Leipzig abgeben am Deadline-Day, das finde ich erstaunlich. Und gleichzeitig holen sie Matt O'Reilly zurück, den sie im Sommer brutal über Haasted abgegeben haben auf einmal. Das habe ich damals schon nicht kommen sehen und nicht verstanden. Jetzt holen sie ihn zurück und Hürzeler sagt öffentlich, der wird uns halt total helfen. Das bezweifle ich, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Ich saß auch am Deadline-Day da und dachte mir, was machen die da? Ganz genau. Und so dünn wie sie jetzt vorne– sie haben Watson dann auch wieder abgegeben, leihweise, und Gruda abgegeben. Sie sind jetzt genau eine Mitoma-Verletzung davon entfernt, dass das Gleiche passiert, was die ganze Saison schon passiert, dass sie absolut Notaufstellungen lösen müssen. Und auch allein der Pascal Groß-Deal, der jetzt ja wieder schon fast ein Monat her ist, der ist grundsätzlich klug, weil das endlich so jemand ist, der eine gewisse Erfahrung und so eine Abgezocktheit reingebracht hat. Von denen hatten sie eigentlich im Kader nur Wellbeck und Milner ansonsten. Vielleicht noch Dank in der Innenverteidigung. Okay, den würde ich ihnen noch geben. Aber alles in allem sind das– also die haben diese Mischung– wir wissen ja alle, Jamestown hängt ja auch bei Nürnberg drin. Die scouten ja sehr, sehr, sehr datenorientiert und haben über all die Jahre viele, viele Projekte gemacht, von denen sich viele ausgezahlt haben, aber manche halt auch überhaupt gar nicht. Und ich würde tippen, dass sie diese Mischung mini auf die Spitze getrieben haben in der Saison.
Jakob?
Zumal doch auch die jetzt von dir angesprochenen Mitterfahrungen sind doch inzwischen aber auch ganz schön über ihren Zenit, oder? Also Dank ist doch auch nicht mehr der Dank, der vor ein paar Jahren auch mal so vielleicht zumindest an der Schwelle zur Nationalmannschaft war, oder?
Also bei Dank würde ich noch leichtere Abstriche machen. Da hast du recht, der hat auch etwas mehr Fehlzeiten als sonst gehabt. Der ist jetzt aber gerade wieder eigentlich ganz gut. Also von Hecke Dank ist so das Prunkstück von Brighton. Das ist immer noch ganz in Ordnung. Der kommt gerade wieder richtig stark. Ich würde dem schon alles in einem ein sehr hohes Niveau nachsagen. Ich finde eher das Problem sind die anderen Erfahrenden, weil die sind zwar theoretisch da, aber ja praktisch nicht. Also was willst du mit James Möller noch spielen mit 40 Jahren? Das ist nice to have.
Er muss den Rekord noch brechen.
Genau, das wird er wahrscheinlich auch tippe ich jetzt mal. Der spielt so lange. Also alles, was Hürzeler immer sagt, ist natürlich schon jemand, der abstrahlt auf die jungen Leute, der das alles genau richtig vorlebt und so weiter. Aber du kannst den halt nicht alle zwei Tage spielen. Das ist völlig unmöglich. Und Danny Welbeck konnte man ja noch nicht mal mit 22 alle drei Tage spielen. Von daher ist auch das, das zieht den Schnitt erst mal hoch. Und Pascal Groß, ich weiß auch nicht, was in Dortmund in dem gestorben ist, aber irgendwas ist es, ist auch nicht mehr derselbe Spieler, hat auch nicht mehr denselben Einfluss. Höchst angesehen ist auch derjenige, der sich gerade am ersten öffentlich äußert zu gewissen Dingen. Nichtsdestotrotz ist das auch nicht mehr der gleiche Spieler. Es ist so ein bisschen so eine kleine Mogelpackung. Es sind schon wahnsinnig viele wahnsinnig rohe Spieler mit drin. Dann darf man vielleicht auch nicht vergessen, Carlos Baleba war letzte Saison einfach fantastisch. Also wie mein Lieblingsspieler, unfassbar, der war einfach überall. So wie Golo Kantetsu allerbesten Zeiten. Den scheinen diese Manchester United Sommergerüchte auch den Kopf verdreht zu haben. Der war jetzt beim African Cup of Nations, auch wenn es nicht weit ging. Sieht auch nicht gut aus, ehrlich gesagt. Also es ist so... Irgendwas passt auch nicht. Der hat so viele Leichtigkeitsfehler drin, Flüchtigkeitsfehler drin. Der scheint alles machen zu wollen und kriegt aber nichts hin. Auch das ist so ein Thema, mit Thomas, von dem ich schon kurz gesagt habe, mit dem sehen die immer eine ganze Ecke stärker aus. Der hat zwischendrin einfach fast 3 Monate gefehlt. Merkt man ihn auch sofort an. Und es gibt halt... Hürzeler, wir haben keinen Taker. Also es gibt keinen, der sozusagen einfach mal was macht oder zum Beispiel auch per Standardsituation macht. Die sind 13. Per Definition, finde ich.
Aber das wäre jetzt nämlich auch meine abschließende Frage gewesen, weil wir haben die Tabellenplatzierung noch nicht gesagt. Das klingt so, als ob Brighton eben ganz unten drin hängen würde, aber eben 13. mit 11 Punkten Vorsprung auf die Abstiegsringe. Und wenn wir in die Vergangenheit von Brighton in Half Albion gucken, dann ist es ja eher die Nachricht, dass sie Erstligist sind, als die Frage eben, wo sie dann innerhalb der ersten Liga liegen. Mir ist schon klar, dass es auch schon mal besser war. Aber was ist denn eigentlich die Erwartungshaltung und ist die überhaupt gerechtfertigt?
Ich war jetzt übrigens nur geraten mit 13, das hatte ich gar nicht im Kopf, aber dann passt das ganz gut. Ja, ich glaube, dass sich über die Jahre die Erwartung auch im Umfeld, dass er grundsätzlich ein sehr Dankbares ist, aber es schon gesteigert hat. Das ging los schon in der letzten Saison Roberto de Zerbi, dass man sich zumindest gerne Borderline Europa League sieht. Und in Wahrheit gibt es aber der Kader halt nicht her. Jetzt kommt natürlich nochmal speziell der vorvergangene, also der erste Hürzeler-Transfer, wo sie so viel Geld ausgegeben haben für ganz viele junge Spieler, von denen auch nicht alle abgehoben sind. Das ist einfach so. Und seitdem habe ich das Gefühl, dass man in Brighton selbst im Umfeld auch so eben genau das möchte, dass man im europäischen Bereich ist. Die Führung, Tony Bloom, ist noch relativ cool. Von allem, was wir wissen. Also es ist jetzt keiner, der sich ganz oft öffentlich äußert. Im Gegenteil, in dem Verein ist es grundsätzlich sehr strukturiert, sehr ruhig. Das heißt, da geht jetzt nicht einfach mal jemand vor die Presse. In England spricht der Sportdirektor sowieso nicht. Da spricht immer nur der Manager. Das heißt, all die Deutungshoheit ist eigentlich bei Fabian Hürzeler, der für mich schon zunehmend frustriert wirkt, weil es immer dieselben Themen sind. Aber ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass da von innen raus Unruhe entsteht. Allerdings muss man auch fairerweise sagen, wir haben das noch nie erlebt. Also das einzige Mal, dass in der Ära Tony Blumen ein Trainer quasi gegangen wurde, in Anführungszeichen, so nicht verlängert wurde in dem Fall, war Roberto de Zerbi. Und der hat so sehr öffentlich gezündelt in der in der Rückrunde, dass es eigentlich so organisch ausgelaufen ist. Potter ist ja abgeworben worden und bei Chris Newton, das ist schon so lange her, da war es irgendwie so Konsens, dass was Neues passieren musste. Also es ist relativ geräuschlos passiert, dass man den einfach auch nicht verlängert hat. Sodass es irgendwie neu ist, die Situation. Und ich auch sehr gespannt bin, inwiefern das Board dann auf den öffentlichen Druck reagiert. Der ist immer noch 50-50. Es gibt schon auch noch die besonnenen Leute in Brighton, die sagen, nee, jetzt Moment mal, also wir müssen schon mal genau drauf schauen. Strukturell hat Hürzeler keine Fehler gemacht. Ich glaube auch, das war aber auch klar, das haben wir hier auch diskutiert, ganz zu Beginn. Diese Art von ihm, die hat eine Halbwertszeit, glaube ich, wenn es nicht läuft. Und es läuft halt gerade nicht. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es seine Schuld ist, aber das wird irgendwann, es war mir klar, dass irgendwann Arroganzvorwürfe und so kommen.
Gleichzeitig muss man sagen, 10 unentschieden, 31 Punkte. Da sieht man, es muss nur zwei-, dreimal der Cointos quasi auf die andere Seite fallen und dann stehst du besser da. Aber gleichzeitig habe ich Jakob still in sich hineinlächeln sehen und zwar glaube ich aus zwei Gründen. Das eine ist erkennt natürlich als FC St. Pauli, Aficionado Fabian Hürzeler auch noch sehr gut und so manche Vorwürfe dieser mit im Raum sind und als Roberto de Servi, der sich dann so ein bisschen weggezündet hat genannt wurde, dachte ich mir, okay, gut, da machen wir jetzt als nächstes die Liga. Jakob, da habe ich irgendwie das Gefühl, es scheint sich ein Muster zu zeigen.
Ja, ganz große Überraschung, dass Roberto de Servi zündet. Also kann ich mir überhaupt nicht erklären und das ist auch bei Marseille definitiv nicht der Fall und deswegen sprechen wir jetzt auch über sie, denn da läuft natürlich wieder alles ganz ruhig. Es ist ja jetzt glaube ich schon das dritte Mal in dieser Saison, dass wir über sie sprechen. Beim ersten Mal war es wegen des Zoffes zwischen Rabiot und Row, die sich gekloppt hatten in der Kabine und dann da schon direkt zum Saisonstart die Hütte brannte. Dann haben wir ja glaube ich im Herbst einmal drüber geredet, als es plötzlich so aussah, als könnten sie in den Titelkampf eingreifen und jetzt sind wir schon wieder dabei, dass der Vulkan ausgebrochen ist, Marseille, denn ich glaube, es ist jedem bewusst, dass es in Frankreich der Verein ist, wo es am ehesten brennt und wo am meisten Unruhe ist und wo eigentlich keine Saison ohne größeres Theater vorbeigeht und das ist jetzt definitiv auch wieder der Fall. Es ist natürlich auch in der sportlichen Situation begründet. Ich meine, in der Liga steht man jetzt neun Punkte hinter PSG, ist also raus aus dem Titelkampf, was wir mal angesprochen hatten. Und dann hat natürlich, glaube ich, jeder mitgekriegt, das Torwarttor von Anatoly Trubin, wodurch Ben Fieker dann wundersamerweise noch weitergekommen ist und das Opfer von diesem Torwarttor war aber Olympique Marseille, die dann nämlich noch aus den Playoff-Rängen gerutscht sind. Und das, obwohl sie, glaube ich, bevor der Spieltag losging, eine 95%ige Wahrscheinlichkeit hatten, sich zu qualifizieren für die Playoffs, weil da nämlich verdammt viel passieren musste, dass sie noch rausfallen. Aber sie haben es dann tatsächlich geschafft, an Spieltag 7 3-0 gegen Liverpool verloren, an Spieltag 8 3-0 bei Club Brügge verloren. Und gut, so eine Niederlage gegen Liverpool hat man sich, glaube ich, auch schon anders vorgestellt, gerade auch aufgrund der Instabilität, die bei Liverpool ja ab und zu zumindest zu sehen ist. Aber ein 3-0 gegen Club Brügge steht völlig außer Frage, dass das auch für die Ansprüche von Marseille absolut daneben ist, zumal auch die Art und Weise, wie sie aufgetreten sind, für große Unstimmigkeiten gesorgt hat, weil sie nämlich dann auch die letzten Minuten gedacht haben, ach ja, reicht ja trotzdem, wir verteidigen jetzt das 0 zu 3. Und dann, ja, hat es aber doch nicht gereicht. Und das war im Grunde dann ja auch nur das eine Tor, was dann aufgrund der Tordifferenz sie rausgekegelt hat. Und ja, es ist auch wirklich passend zum Verlauf und zu diesen Auf- und Abs, die man in Marseille immer hat, dass sie eigentlich vorher einen Achtungserfolg gefeiert hatten in der Liga, nämlich gegen den bis dato noch Tabellenführer Lens gewonnen hatten, auch in relativ souveräner Art und Weise. Also da vielleicht sogar die leise Hoffnung gehegt haben, dass sie noch mal die Top 2 angreifen können. Dann aber halt das Ausscheiden in der Champions League. Dann haben sie am nächsten Spieltag auch in der Liga eigentlich 2-0 gegen Paris FC geführt, dann aber sich noch ein 2-2 gefangen. Und zwischen diesen beiden Spielen wurde auch schon spekuliert, dass der Serbi angeblich seinen Rücktritt angeboten hätte. Das hat er später aber dementiert. Ist jetzt mal wieder so ein bisschen die Frage, wer da recht hat. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, wo diese Spekulation herkommen sollte, wenn da nicht zumindest Gespräche in die Richtung geführt worden wären. Es gab auch ein Treffen zwischen dem Präsidenten Longoria, dem Sportdirektor Benazir, der Serbi war da auch bei und andere Verantwortliche und auch den Fan-Vertretern, weil die natürlich auch mit dem sportlichen Abschneiden und diesen ganzen Ereignissen jetzt wieder nicht zufrieden sind. Um einfach die Wogen ein bisschen zu glätten, dass vielleicht wieder alle an einem Strang ziehen. Denn man muss sagen, die Stimmung und die Unterstützung der Fans ist eigentlich trotz dieser ständigen Unruhen auch weiterhin da. Also es gibt natürlich häufig Unmutbekundung, wenn es nicht so gut läuft. Aber es ist nicht so, dass das Stadion leer ist oder die Mannschaft nicht unterstützt wird. Die Fans sind schon auch da sehr, sehr passioniert dahinter. Und in Frankreich auf jeden Fall auch eine der ja enthusiastischen und auch größten Fanbasen, die es gibt. Und ja, es sind dann auch noch andere Dinge schon wieder passiert. Denn man hatte ja auch im Januar, das hatte ich glaube ich in der letzten Folge kurz angerissen, den Supercup verloren gegen PSG. Was jetzt an sich natürlich nicht so dramatisch ist, weil es ja nicht so der allerwichtigste Wettbewerb ist. Es ist aber im Kontext Marseille durchaus wichtig, denn sie haben seit 2011, 2012, seit der Saison, keinen Titel mehr geholt. Und das entspricht halt auch gar nicht ihrem Selbstverständnis, den sie sehen sich, glaube ich, eigentlich als der größte Verein in Frankreich. Natürlich muss man akzeptieren, dass das hinter PSG eigentlich inzwischen schon ist. Aber es haben halt auch viele andere Vereine seitdem einen Titel geholt und Marseille eben nicht. Und dann auch diese bittere Niederlage gegen PSG, auch in der Art und Weise, dass sie eigentlich führten, sich dann in Führung liegend in der Nachspielzeit auskontern lassen und dann im Elfmeterschießen verlieren, hat auch nicht unbedingt dazu beigetragen, dass man jetzt so das große Vertrauen in der Serbien hat. Und es gibt einfach auch so wahnsinnig viele, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man es Nebenkriegsschauplätze nennen mag. Es sind einfach so viele Brandherde in diesem Verein. Also es gibt so viele Gründe für Unruhe. Wir hatten ja den Kabinenkampf vor der Saison angesprochen. Jetzt gab es im Training eine Auseinandersetzung, wohl auch wieder körperliche Art und Weise zwischen Condogbia und Vermeeren. Also da stimmt es auch nicht. Dann gab es ja in der letzten Saison, dass der Serbi sie wochenlang in ein Trainingslager mitten während der Saison geschickt hatte. Also es brennt wieder an allen Ecken und Enden. Und man hat jetzt auch im Wintertransferfenster nicht unbedingt die Situation beruhigt und gesagt, okay, wir versuchen jetzt mal, vielleicht hier zumindest durch wenig Transferaktionismus aufzufallen, sondern sie haben dann auch im Wintertransferfenster wieder vier Neuzugänge geholt, neun Spieler abgegeben. Und es ist so ein Wildes Hin und Her. Und das, nachdem man ja im Sommer, glaube ich, auch schon mindestens 25 Transferbewegungen hatte, also den Kader einmal komplett auf links gedreht hatte, wo man gedacht hat, okay, man könnte eigentlich auf der letzten Saison, wo sie ja recht souverän zweiter geworden sind, vielleicht aufbauen. Und man hat halt auch überhaupt nicht das Gefühl, dass der Serbis sich auf irgendwas festlegen mag. Denn sie spielen mal Dreierkette, mal Viererkette. Und auch die Spieler werden teils wild hin und her geschoben. Also Timothy Weah zum Beispiel ist da so ein Paradebeispiel. Der ist relativ flexibel. Der spielt dann mal links außen in einem 4-2-3-1. Dann spielt er rechter Wingback in einem 3-4-3. Dann spielt er rechter Verteidiger in einer Viererkette und wird da hin und her geschoben, wie sonst was. Und ich hatte in der letzten Folge, als wir positiver über Marcel gesprochen hatten, beispielsweise auch angesprochen, dass man das Gefühl hat, dass man mit Arthur Vermeeren jetzt im Zentralen Mittelfeld so eine gute Konstante gefunden hat, der der Mannschaft total hilft. Der ist jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen eher wieder nur Ersatzspieler, hat dann auch gegen Nantes zum Beispiel eine rote Karte gekriegt, völlig unnötig für einen Faul in der 20. Minute oder so im hohen Pressing gegen den Keeper, wo er ihm dann voll auf den Unterschenkel gestiegen ist. Und dann hat Marseille das Spiel gegen Nantes, die zu dem Zeitpunkt auch total am Boden waren, eigentlich verloren, total unnötig in Unterzahl. Und dazu kommt halt die Art und Weise von de Serbi, dass er einfach in der öffentlichen Kommunikation auch nicht so glücklich und souverän agiert. Also er hat sich dann vor ein paar Wochen auch wieder darüber beschwert, dass die Medien ja immer nur gegen Marseille schreiben würden. Hat da also vielleicht auch versucht, natürlich so eine Wagenburg-Mentalität zu erzeugen. Aber es ist halt auch mit den Äußerungen, die von Longoria und von Benazja immer kommen, die dann auch den Schiedsrichtern vorwerfen, dass sie nur gegen Marseille pfeifen würden. Und alles hätte sich gegen OM verschworen. Und das wirkt dann natürlich auf Dauer, nutzt sich das halt auch einfach ab. Und ergibt halt auch der eigenen Mannschaft keine Rückendeckung. Jetzt hat da in der letzten Woche auch einen der wenigen Spieler, die schon ein bisschen länger dabei sind, angezählt. Mit Amir Murio hat gesagt, dass der seinem Niveau überhaupt nicht entsprechen würde. Und ihn jetzt aussortiert hat. Und dass der einfach nicht zu seiner Art und Weise Fußball passen würde. Und das Niveau nicht hätte, wo man sich auch so denkt, also warum? Der weiß eh, dass er jetzt nicht absoluter Stammspieler ist. Das ist so völlig unnötig jetzt einen, also diesen Spieler anzuzählen. Das ist der Dessert, oder?
Ist es nicht? Also Uli nickt auch die ganze Zeit schon.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, so ist er halt, oder? Also ich kann vielleicht ganz kurz aus Italien, was ich so ein bisschen mitkriege, weil da sind logisch die Verbindungen schon da. Er ist, wie er ist. Genau, das glaube ich wussten die davor auch schon. Und dieses zum Beispiel das Gerücht, dass er seinen Rücktritt angeboten hätte. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein typischer Dezert. Der wird halt mal in einer Sitzung gesagt haben, du ganz ehrlich, wenn ich das Problem bin, dann gehe ich. So, das ist halt, das kommt bei dem immer wieder. Also was ich mitbekommen habe, er hat ja nicht wirklich seinen Rücktritt angeboten. Das ist halt Teil des Pakets bei ihm. Und die viele Unruhe, die kommt, muss man ihm glaube ich schon zu gut erhalten im Verein. Die kommt jetzt nicht nur von ihm. Also die gibt es be Marseilles historisch.
Nein, nicht nur von ihm, klar.
Genau, die gibt es historisch drum herum. Und was er zum Beispiel, du hast das ja auch schon gesagt, was er auch in Italien immer wieder angesprochen hat, er sagt, das kann er sich auch schwierig erklären. Und dann nimmt er sich logisch in Verantwortung. Dieses Auf und Ab eben, wie du sagst, immer ein richtig gutes Spiel. Und dann ein Spiel später schaut alles schon komplett anders aus. Also definitiv das nimmt er auf seine Kappe, was man ihm vielleicht wirklich auch ein bisschen zugutehalten kann. Du hast es auch schon angesprochen. Also die Fluktiation im Kader, das ist ja crazy. Also die hatten im Sommer, hat er erzählt, auch zwölf Abgänge im Sommer. Und jetzt, wie du sagst, im Winter nochmal neun. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das alles auf seinen Mist wächst. Also da ist schon das Drumherum, auch Penatial, Longoria. Also ja, ist halt ein Pulverfass, Marseille. Und wenn du dir dann halt so einen emotionalen Dessert noch dazu holst, ja, dann beruhigst du das Feuer halt nicht unbedingt. Also ich möchte gern noch kurz hier die Zahlen nennen. Da sind jetzt natürlich auch Leinen mit dabei, aber 30 Zugänge und 29 Abgänge innerhalb dieser beiden Transferperioden im Sommer. Also 59 Kaderbewegungen, das ist, wie gesagt, sind ein paar Leinen und so weiter mit dabei. Aber ja, um das nochmal zu unterstreichen.
Ja, es ist halt eine ganz interessante Kombination. Denn Longoria war ja früher auch mal eher so auf der Sportdirektoren-Ebene unterwegs und der jetzt Präsident ist bei Marseille und Benassia ist ja der nominelle Sportdirektor. Und so geht es halt aber seitdem Longoria da ist, hat man immer das Gefühl, dass er so ein bisschen dieses Trading-Modell halt hat, dass der Spieler schnell holt, dann sie wieder abgibt und so. Aber es ist halt nicht so wie bei anderen Vereinen, die das machen. Es kommt halt auch häufig gar nicht so viel bei rum. Also sie geben dann halt auch Spieler gar nicht unbedingt mit Gewinn wieder ab, sondern verbrennen die eher, hat man das Gefühl. Und es ist so ein reiner Durchlauferhitzer. Sie haben jetzt in dieser Transferphase tatsächlich auch mal ja ein paar Spieler durchaus für besseres Geld abgegeben. Also haben zum Beispiel für einen 18-jährigen Rubinho Vaz, der jetzt eher Ergänzungsspieler war, 22 Millionen bekommen. Für Daryl Bacula, der zu Sassolo gegangen ist im Doppelpack mit Konee, insgesamt 20 Millionen gekriegt. Also dafür Spieler, die jetzt nicht die zentrale Rolle gespielt haben, wo man sich aber halt auch fragt, allein aufgrund des Alters, ob es nicht zumindest langfristig schöner gewesen wäre, diese Spieler zu halten, da sie dann ja eher die Zukunft des Vereins wären. Anstattdessen hat man jetzt Ethan Waneri von Arsenal ausgeliehen, der jetzt eine halbe Saison erst mal da ist. Aber wo ich mir jetzt nicht sicher bin, ob der langfristige Plan sein kann, dass der bei Marseille eine Schlüsselfigur wird. Denn ich glaube eigentlich nicht, dass man den bei Arsenal schon aufgegeben hat. Also ich gehe mal eher davon aus, dass der Spielpraxis sammeln soll. Und dann ist es halt eigentlich für einen Verein mit den Ansprüchen von Marseille ziemlich quatsch, so einen Spieler auszuleihen, wo man gar nicht unbedingt die Perspektive hat, dass der jetzt längerfristig da bleiben kann.
Also ein bisschen ist alles wie immer, aber mit neuen Noten. Und es würde ja auch total zu Olympique passen, wenn sie jetzt dann ihr nächstes Spiel gewinnen. Gewinnen wäre es glaube ich richtig formuliert. Das ist nämlich gegen PSG zu Hause. Und das könnte natürlich wirklich interessant werden. Also PSG ist für Marseille schon weg, weil da sind es die neuen Punkte, die du vorhin zitiert hast. Aber L'Anse ist immer noch zwei Punkte dahinter.
Das heißt, das Hinspiel hat Marseille ja auch gewonnen.
Genau. Da hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal kurz drüber gesprochen. Also gucken wir mal. Und ja, auf jeden Fall Roberto Di Sarbi. Es wird nie langweilig mit ihm. Ich sag's mal so. Das ist doch gut zu wissen. Dann wollen wir mal nach Spanien blicken. Alex, du hast jetzt schon als längstes nichts mehr gesagt. Als erstes reden wir über Atletico. Bei Atletico haben vielleicht die Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen. Die haben ganz schön gebuttert auf dem Transfermarkt, würde ich jetzt sagen. Was ist denn dabei rumgekommen?
Ja, das ist der Aufhänger quasi dieses Thema. Ademola Lukman wurde jetzt frisch verpflichtet und das nutzen wir so ein bisschen als Aufmacher. Wir haben ja mit Christian auch jemanden da, der dazu auch was beisteuern kann. Sehr, sehr spannender Transfer. Ein bisschen unter dem Radar, also hinter den Kulissen eingefädelt. Normalerweise bauscht sich das ja gerade medial eher auf. So ein großer Transfer, 35 Millionen. Lukman ist ja jetzt kein komplett Unbekannter. Hetrick geschossen im Europa League-Finale gegen Leverkusen. Letztes Jahr super funktioniert. Ich glaube, Christian 15 Tore in 30 Spielen. Und den haben sie so ein bisschen im Geheimen eingefädelt für ein schlanke 35 Millionen. Und das führt uns zu einem größeren Thema, nämlich das, wie du schon gesagt hast, Atletico reinbuttert, also auf dem Transfermarkt viel Geld ausgibt. Jetzt im Sommer 35 nur für Luckmann, jetzt im Winter, sorry, insgesamt über 200 Millionen, ich glaube 230 Millionen in dieser Saison. Und was kommt bei rum? 10 Punkte Rückstand am 5. Februar hinter dem Tabellenführer FC Barcelona. Also eine spannende Thematik bei Atletico, die meiner Meinung nach quasi unterperformen gemessen, an dem, was sie alles investieren in den Kader.
Aber wie kommt denn das zustande? Weil wenn ich mir nämlich die Tabelle angucke, dann sieht alles genauso aus wie immer. Also Rang 3, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Rückstand, als man normalerweise zu diesem Saisonzweigpunkt hatte. Dann schaue ich mir das Torverhältnis an und sehe, ah, okay, die Defensive ist mal wieder. Also jetzt in dem Fall ist es sogar aktuell die beste der spanischen Liga. Offensive, ja, geht so. Fast halb so viele Tore wie Barca. Also jetzt ein bisschen ganz grob gerechnet. Aber das sieht ehrlicherweise so aus wie immer und sieht auch aus wie das, was du halt bekommst, wenn du Diego Simeone als Trainer hast. Ist es denn so, dass jetzt dann angesichts dieser Transferbewegung dann auch bei Atletico– was kippt hinsichtlich Kritik an ihm?
Ne, eben nicht. Und das ist meiner Meinung nach auch das Problem, weil wenn du sagst, alles ist wie immer, ja. Aber ist nicht genau das das Problem, dass du so viel Geld ausgibst, also 230 Millionen der Saison, in der letzten Saison auch 190 oder so. Also in zwei Jahren über 400 Millionen investiert. Das ist eine Menge für– noch mal, wir reden nicht von Barcelona, von Real Madrid, nicht von Man City, nicht von Arsenal, von Liverpool. Wir reden von Atletico. Das ist schon sehr, sehr viel, dass sie investieren. Es benötigte auch einen Umbruch, vor allem in der letzten Saison. Das ist schon richtig, dass sie da was machen. Aber dass du dann nur Dritter bist, stagnierst, sehr, sehr viele Spiele nicht gewinnst, 10 Punkte Rückstand. Also, Dritter sein ist ja an sich keine Schande hinter Real und dem FC Barcelona, aber mit 10 Punkten Rückstand Dritter sein. Max, das ist dann schon etwas, wo wir über Underperforming reden. Wenn wir uns die Zahlen anschauen, 9 von 22 Ligaspielen in der Saison haben sie nicht gewonnen. Das entspricht 40 Prozent der Spiele. Das ist Underperforming gemessen an dem eigenen Anspruch, gemessen an deinem Investment. Auswärts haben sie 3 von 11 Ligaspielen gewonnen. Das sind nicht die Zahlen eines– ich nenne es mal– Top-Teams, eines Contenders um die Meisterschaft. Eine Mannschaft, die da oben zumindest mitspielen will. Jetzt sind sie Dritter, also sie sind da oben, aber mit riesem Abstand. Das wird dem Anspruch und den Investitionen, meiner Meinung nach, nicht gerecht. Und vor allem, wenn du bedenkst und drauf blickst, gegen welche Mannschaften sie regelmäßig immer wieder Punkte in La Liga lassen. Das sind Mittelklassemannschaften, das sind Abstiegskandidaten in der Saison. Mallorca, Elche, Alaves, Celta, Vigo und Levante. Das sind Teams, die musst du eigentlich schlagen. Und klar, du kannst dir mal hier und da einen Patzer erlauben. Keiner sagt ja, du musst immer alles gewinnen. Aber das sind fünf Teams, die musst du schlagen. Und du hast keins dieser fünf gewonnen, um ihn nur jetzt diese fünf zu nennen. Natürlich gegen Real und Barca ist es dann erst recht schwer. Wobei Real Madrid ja sogar 5 zu 2 abgekoffert wurde in La Liga. Aber sie an der Performen grundsätzlich gemessen an dem Investment, gemessen an den großen Ausgaben. Und das ist schon, finde ich, ein Thema, das man mal ansprechen darf und sollte. Und bei den Rojiblancos wird das eben nicht so knallhart und kritisch gesehen. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ein Problem.
Kommt denn dieses hohe Investment, also wenn man jetzt die letzten zwei, drei Jahre anguckt, dann hat nur Real noch mehr Geld ausgegeben als Atletico. Und vor allem, man hat beide haben einen krassen Vorsprung vor Barca, weil wir haben es ja auch alle mitbekommen, die konnten ja gar nicht so viel Geld ausgeben. Ist das vielleicht auch der Grund für diese Transfer-Offensive, dass man jetzt so ein Fenster sieht unter den Financial-Airplay-Regeln, die eben für La Liga selbst gelten, wo Barca wirklich die Hände gebunden sind am Transfermarkt, dass man irgendwie den Angriff schaffen kann. Also man gehört ja schon immer zu den Top 3, aber quasi sich näher dran zu schieben an die oberen beiden oder zumindest an Barca. Kommt das daher?
Ja, woher es kommt, ist schwer zu sagen. Im Endeffekt war der Umbruch nötig. Ich habe es ja kurz schon thematisiert. Eine überalterte Mannschaft vor zwei Jahren. Viele Spieler mussten auch ausgewechselt werden, gerade in der Abwehr mussten sie was tun. Jetzt im Mittelfeld beispielsweise. Sie haben ja gerade Gallager abgegeben, den sie vor zwei Jahren für 40 Euro haben. Jetzt für 40 wieder an das Börs verkauft, obwohl der im besten Fußballeralter ist und absoluter Stammspieler. Also alle Transferbewegungen sind auch nicht immer nachvollziehbar. Hatte er Heimwege? Hatte er unbedingt um die Freigabe gebeten? Das weiß ich jetzt natürlich nicht. Das wird nur Gallager wissen. Aber schon interessant, welche Bewegungen sie machen, vor allem wie oft sie immer wieder Spieler kaufen und frühzeitig verkaufen. Also Raspardori hat es jetzt ein halbes Jahr ausgehalten, für 22 Millionen von Napoli gekauft im Sommer. Der hat kaum gespielt, war Edeljoker und nach, ich weiß gar nicht, zehn Einsätzen, wahrscheinlich achter von der Bank, flüchtete er wieder nach Italien, war aber auch nicht ganz so günstig. Und da gibt es viele, viele Beispiele. Sie kaufen Spiele, die funktionieren nicht und dann verkaufen sie sie wieder und investieren das Geld oder reinvestieren wieder, nehmen natürlich auch viel Geld ein. Sie waren ja in diesem Sommer beim Club World Cup, da gab es einiges an Kohle. Durch Riot Air, den Sponsor, gibt es sehr, sehr viel Geld. Er ist Namensponsor des Stadions und der Brust. Das ist ja Sportswashing, wenn man das so nennen sollte, darf, was die betreiben. Die Airline gibt es ja noch nicht mal wirklich. Da steckt auch der Public Investment Fund dahinter, der Newcastle gekauft hat oder alimentiert. Da fließt schon Geld in den Verein. Das investieren sie. Sie müssen auch, um mitzuhalten mit den Top 2, logisch. Aber sie können es eben nicht gut genug, meiner Meinung nach, obwohl sie so viel investieren.
Soll ich mal ganz kurz bei den Italienern, bei den Namen nehmen, die ja schon vielen reingehen. Also, erstens finde ich, fairerweise muss man ihnen schon zugute halten. Sie nehmen ja auch viel Geld ein bei Verkäufen. Also, Alex hat sie gerade gesagt, wenn du Geld für 40 abgibst. Raspordori haben sie zum Beispiel auch nichts verloren. Sie haben jetzt für so viel wieder ein Atalanta verkauft, wie sie ihn geholt haben, dass es logisch, glaube ich, nicht ideal ist, nach einem halben Jahr einen Spieler schon wieder abzugeben. Keine Frage. Aber sie haben jetzt in der Saison auch 150 Millionen eingenommen. Das ist nur vielleicht so, sonst klingt es so, als würden die da nur hunderte von Millionen raushauen. Raspadoare ist für mich, Alex, sag du gerne, ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass sie halt in der Offensive, also nicht nur quantitativ, sondern auch qualitativ, ich weiß nicht, wie sie sich das vorgestellt haben, wie die da alle spielen sollen. Raspadoare ist ja das beste Beispiel. Der hat es als Chance gesehen, da hinzukommen. Bei der Offensive läuft ja schon ordentlich was rum an Qualität. Dann kommt er halt kaum dran. Bei Raspadoare geht es halt auch darum, falls Italiener zur WM kommen, würde er halt auch gerne zur WM. Und dann sagt er sich halt, ja, dann gehe ich jetzt nach Italien zurück und spiele noch ein halbes Jahr da, um mir Spielpraxis zu holen. Und zu Lukmen, also was ich aus Italien mitbekommen habe, es war wirklich eine Aktion der letzten zwei, drei Tage. Lukmen war in der Türkei lange im Gespräch, das hat ihm aber nicht so gepasst. Und dann ist das wirklich sau schnell gegangen. Das zeigt irgendwie auch die wirtschaftliche Kraft von Atletico, dass sie dann das Geld hinlegen können, denn Atalanta gibt nur ab, wenn der Preis passt. Das hat Inter letzten Sommer mitbekommen, da wollte sich Lukmen hinklagen, da ist Atalanta einfach stur geblieben. Und jetzt kriegen sie ungefähr das Geld, das sie wollten, 35, das sind auch noch fünf Bonus, die wollten so um die 40. Und von dem her bin ich gespannt, weil Lukmen kann man diese Saison halt kaum bewerten. Also der hat bei Atalanta kaum gespielt, weil er eben im Sommer sich da ja wegstreiken wollte, dann war er verletzt, dann war er jetzt beim Afrika Cup. Also ich sage mal so, aus Atalantas Sicht, glaube ich, war das jetzt ein guter Move, auf seinen Vertrag werden nur noch eineinhalb Jahre gelaufen, also Sommer 207. Das Kapitel ist zu Ende und wenn du jetzt aus Atalantas sich da mit knapp 40 rausgehst, für einen Spieler, der dir in den Saisonen eigentlich kaum sportlich groß was gebracht hat.
Drei Tore, glaube ich, hat er geschossen oder zwei.
Der war nie wirklich drin, aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Aber ich bin bei dir, wenn Lukmen wieder in Form kommt, dann ist das schon einer, mit dem du was anfangen kannst. Also ich glaube, das haben die letzten Jahre schon gezeigt.
Ich finde es spannend, weil sie vorne mit Alvarez und Sirlo, also ich bin ja viel zu zweit normalerweise.
Dann ist Griezmann auch noch da.
Sirlo der Brecher im Sturm und Alvarez hat dann mehr Freiheiten. Aber wir sind beim Thema, warum wenn sie die beiden haben und Griezmann dahinter, der jetzt mit, ich glaube, 34 ist er eher so der Edeljoker wird oder der immer wieder dosierter eingesetzt wird. Also nicht mehr Stammstamm ist Griezmann zuletzt eben viel eingewechselt worden. Aber sie haben eigentlich dann drei Top-Männer, mit verschiedenen Optionen, die verschieden zu benutzen. Und trotzdem investieren sie 35 Millionen für einen Offensivmann, der, was ist Lockman, hängende Spitze, kann, glaube ich, links außen auch spielen. Ist das notwendig, könnte man da fragen. Aber ich glaube, sie haben es auch getan mit Blick auf Julian Alvarez, Situation aktuell und vielleicht sogar Situation im Sommer. Also das ist jetzt ein bisschen spekulativ von mir, aber so würde das, glaube ich, Sinn ergeben. Zum einen funktioniert Alvarez gerade gar nicht mehr. Da schießt kaum noch Tore. Ich habe es mir notiert. Zwei Tore in den letzten 15 Spielen, zehn Spiele am Stück ohne Tor. Und Achtung, letztes Ligatour war am 1. November. Also irgendwas ist da im Argen, natürlich auch oft dem…
Aus dem Spiel raus gar nichts, ne?
Ganz genau. Dem Spiel geschuldet. Man weiß ja, Atletico, die stürmen jetzt nicht immer. Die haben Heimspiele, da sind sie schon mal stürmischer. Aber in Auswärtsspielen wird da gern bis zur 70. auf 0-0 gespielt und dann ist man zufrieden und dann hindraus probiert man es ein bisschen. Das ist ja dann auch ein anderes Thema, warum sie so viele Punkte ständig liegen lassen. Aber der hat seine Form völlig eingebüßt und kommt und ja, ich will nicht sagen, nimmt nicht am Spielteil oder ist ein Fremdkörper. Das sind so Doppelpassparolen. Aber es geht schon in die Richtung. Das kannst du dir nicht erklären. Gleichzeitig Sirloot hat zuletzt, ich glaube, 5 Tore in 7 oder 8 Spielen. Also den finden sie, da schön die Flanke am zweiten Pfosten, dann nickt er die ein. Aber Alvarez ist komplett neben der Spur. Vielleicht haben sie auch mit Blick auf seine Form in Lugman einen neuen Mann geholt und mit Blick auf Sommer, weil es gibt ja Abwanderungsgerüchte. Nicht nur, dass er unzufrieden ist, weil er wenig Bälle bekommt, wenig im Spiel eingebunden ist. Dann verdrehen ihm manche Vereine vielleicht auch den Kopf. Die Thematik Alvarez hängt vielleicht mit der Thematik Lugman und umgekehrt zusammen.
Das ist so interessant, wie sich Atletico verändert hat. Man kann es im Grunde auch nachhören in alten Ligatouren noch. Die hatten auch mal dieses Werbevideo mit, wo sie aus dem Gullideckel hochschieben und dann quasi in Madrid auftauchen. Das dreckige Atletico und dann haben sie all diese Erfolge, aber halt mit dem Fußball. Wir alle haben es ja gesehen und so weiter und so fort. Jetzt schmeißen sie links und rechts Geld raus, haben saudische Sponsoren, ein neues Stadion und so weiter und so fort. Also so, wie man auch bei Barca ganz viel nach erzählen kann, ist es bei Atletico genauso, finde ich. Also Barca, glaube ich, als wir gestartet sind mit dem Rasenfunk, hatten sie noch gar keinen Trikotsponsor. Dann kam Unicef und völlig überraschend war das die Vorbereitung für einen Trikotsponsor und so weiter und so fort. Willst gar nicht ein neues Thema aufmachen, aber bei Atletico ist es halt ganz genauso einfach, wie sie sich entwickelt haben. Und das Ganze aber ja, Alex, auch in einem interessanten Kontext, weil nämlich Atletico jetzt richtig investiert hat, diese Transferperioden und in der letzten Saison. Aber für die Liga als Gesamtes gilt das ja gar nicht. Also ich habe jetzt als wieder so die Bilanzsummen kamen, was die einzelnen Ligen investiert haben in diesem Winter, habe ich durchaus einige Skiz bei Blue Sky gesehen von Journalisten, die eben sich mit dem spanischen Fußball auseinandersetzen, die fast schon ein bisschen Alarm geschlagen haben, so wie wir es hier ja vor ein paar Wochen auch schon mal beschrieben haben, dass da La Liga wirklich zurückfällt, was einfach so Investitionen angeht. Aber betrifft hat Atletico nicht.
Ja, das ist ja das Spannende. Deswegen hatte ich es ja auch jetzt als Thema aufgebracht, sie haben in diese Saison und in der letzte Saison das meiste Geld aller Vereine in Spanien ausgegeben. Also nicht Real und Barca. Bei Barca kennt man ja die Gründe. Aber es ist ja trotzdem spannend, weil das finde ich schon so ein bisschen in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung unterm Radar läuft, dass die da richtig investieren. Klar, Christian hat es angesprochen, sie nehmen natürlich auch immer wieder Geld ein. Also das ist jetzt nicht Netto-Ausgaben von über 400 Millionen, aber trotzdem 400 Millionen in zwei Jahren. Du magst ja oft Bundesliga-Vergleiche. Ich wollte nämlich den BVB bemühen so ein bisschen. Stell dir vor, der BVB gibt 400 Millionen in zwei Jahren aus und landet trotzdem 10, 15 Punkte immer hinter den Bayern und ist im Februar schon außer Reichweite der Meisterschaft und kann da gar nicht mithalten, während die Bayern eben nicht so viel Geld ausgeben. Schwieriger Vergleich, ich weiß, aber die Ansprüche wären ja andere.
Das ist ein total schiefer Vergleich, weil er setzt voraus, dass Sebastian Kehl überhaupt genügend Spieler kennt, für die er 400 Millionen ausgeben könnte.
Okay, kleiner Kehl-Seit, nehmt gefällt mir. Ich will nur sagen, stell dir vor, das wäre der Fall bei zum Beispiel im BVB und die würden so underperformen und titellos bleiben in der Copa. Gut, jetzt spielen sie heute in der Copa del Rey, vielleicht ziehen sie ins Halbfinale ein, aber das letzte Jahr, wir sind ja auch früh ausgeschieden, das Jahr davor auch in der Supercopa, wieder gegen das schwächste Real Madrid seit Jahren verloren. In der Liga, wie gesagt, zehn, letztes Jahr waren es glaube ich 15 Punkte Rückstand. Also stell dir vor, dieses Underperforming bei zum Beispiel dem BVB, wenn der BVB 400 Millionen ausgibt. Das stimmen dann Anspruch und Ertrag nicht ganz. Keiner sagt, die müssen Meister werden oder die müssen irgendwie, aber sie sollten nicht so weit weg sein, so früh in der Saison und jedes Jahr recht frühzeitig aus allen Wettbewerben ausscheiden und vor allem gegen wen sie verlieren und wie sie verlieren. Gegen Bode, Glimt in der Champions League, bei Galatasaray nur unentschieden gespielt und, und, und. Also wir reden ja gar nicht von den Top-Teams, mit denen sie nicht immer mithalten können, sondern sie lassen halt Punkte liegen in den kleinen Spielen gegen kleine Teams. Bei so viel Investitionen und so viel Ansprüchen sollte das anders sein.
Da ist gerade die Zwischenrunde gegen Brügge noch mal interessanter geworden, jetzt mit dem Letzten, was du gesagt hast. Also wir werden es verfolgen, was bei Atletico passiert. Und was wir erstaunlich wenig verfolgt haben bisher in der Ligatur, deswegen arbeiten wir da jetzt mal gegen, ist die Situation bei Inter. Denn die haben sich, für dich nicht, aber für alle anderen still und leise, nämlich jetzt dann doch einen Vorsprung erarbeitet in der Serie A. Wir haben die ganzen letzten Wochen das immer wieder begleitet. Wir haben viel über Napoli gesprochen. Wir haben über den AC gesprochen, die AC. Und jetzt müssen wir aber mal über Inter sprechen, denn die sind fünf Punkte voraus auf Rang 1. Ja, sollten wir mal. Ich glaube, wir haben nämlich Christian Kivo und also das neue Inter unter Kivo noch gar nicht richtig beleuchtet. Und deswegen passt das ganz gut. Du sagst es ja, fünf Punkte Vorsprung. Sie haben jetzt zehn der letzten elf in der Liga gewonnen. Also im Prinzip, sie gewinnen alles, was sie gewinnen müssen. Was ihnen noch ein bisschen fehlt, ist ein Erfolg gegen den Großen, also sowohl in der Liga, in den Topspielen gegen Milan, Napoli, Juve, als eben auch in der Champions League, wo sie dann gegen Liverpool und Arsenal zuletzt verloren haben, auch bei Atletico zum Beispiel 0-1 in der Nachspielzeit verloren haben. Aber ich glaube, es ist wirklich höchste Zeit, mal so ein bisschen das Neue hinter zu beleuchten, weil, ja, Simone Insagi im Sommer ja weg. Und dann war ja schon die Frage, Christian Kiewo, da kommt einer, der hatte halt 13 Spiele, Erfahrung als Profi-Trainer. Ja, wie macht er das? Und ich würde sagen, jetzt, was haben wir jetzt? Anfang Februar kann man festhalten, das läuft, das funktioniert. Also, das ist ein sehr guter Fit. Kiewo vielleicht ganz kurz, ja, er hat nur 13 Spiele Profi-Trainer-Auffahrung, aber er war lang in der Inter-Jugend, hat die Primavera trainiert, also kennt das Umfeld, kennt auch die Clubstruktur. Und was ich glaube, was auch wichtig ist, er war halt als Spieler auch einer, der große Kabinen gelebt hat, hat ja mit Inter das Triple gewonnen, war mit 20 schon Kapitän bei Ajax, das waren vielleicht auch nicht alle auf dem Schirm, also war dann bei der Roma, also ich würde sagen, diese Kombination aus, also der hat was, darauf kommen wir gleich zu sprechen, was er macht, dann hat er eine große Erfahrung als Spieler, die ihm glaube ich in der Kabine zugutekommt, weil er sehr gut bei den Spielern ankommt und das Kennen von Inter eben, also die Clubstruktur, auch die Rückendeckung von Marotta und Co., das glaube ich hat halt dazu geführt, dass wir jetzt Anfang Februar darüber sprechen können, dass Kiwund und Inter schon richtig gut in der Spur sind. Haben wir ja auch gesehen, unter anderem beim BVB, ohne jetzt zu tief ins Spiel reinzugehen, aber da ist mir Inter wieder so Vintage-mäßig vorgekommen. Es war jetzt nicht so, dass sie da das beste Spiel überhaupt gemacht haben, aber das, was sie können, das haben sie aufs Feld gebracht und haben halt dann sehr, sehr gute Einsaktionen und vor allem ab dem 1 zu 0, ich meine, es ist ja auch erst relativ spät gefallen, aber du hattest halt nie aus Inters Sicht jetzt das Gefühl, okay, hier wird jetzt nochmal was passieren. Und ich glaube, daher kam auch der Frust vieler BVB-Fans, dass es sich genauso auch für Dortmund angefühlt hat. Ist es auch quasi so die Qualität von Inter, dass sie eben wieder so wie früher, wenn sie erst mal 1-0 führen, dann ist das Spiel im Grunde vorbei? Also, sie sind auch defensiv stabil, genau, da kommen wir gleich drauf zu sprechen. Aber eigentlich, wenn wir jetzt mal weg von der Champions League gehen, wenn wir uns die Liga anschauen, also die sind mit Abstand die beste Offensive der Liga. Sie haben 52 Tore in 23 Spielen gemacht. Also wirklich, mit Abstand sind die alten offensiven Statistiken in der Liga herausragend. Ich habe eine Zahl, die finde ich beeindruckend. Es gibt hier die Kategorie der Großchancen, also Top-Chancen, einfach richtig gute Chancen. Da haben die 99 jetzt und der zweite in der Liga hat 67. Also hier haben sich ein Drittel mehr Top-Chancen in der Liga herausgespielt, als der Zweitbeste der Liga, als die Milan, Juves und Co. Also offensiv ist das wirklich, das rollt weiterhin, das fängt an, dass logisch Lautaro funktioniert. Turam, dazu haben sie jetzt in der Saison mit Pio Sposito und Boni junge neue Stürmer bekommen, die sofort funktionieren. Also Chivo mischt die wunderbar mit ein. Pio Sposito haben wir ja schonmal angesprochen, der 20-jährige Italiener. Also wirklich auf einem richtig, richtig guten Weg. Harmoniert zum Beispiel wunderbar mit Lautaro, aber auch die Kombination mit Turam, mit Boni. Also die vier funktionieren. Das ist ein riesen Upgrade zur vergangenen Saison. Da hatten wir immer das Thema Lautaro und Turam und dann kam lange nichts mit Anatovic und Taremi. Und jetzt hast du zwei Stürmer, die funktionieren, die liefern. Boni hat jetzt auch gestern wieder in der Coppa Italia das 1-0 gemacht. Also da ist eine neue Dynamik reingekommen. Dann hast du mit Di Marco– spielt wieder eine herausragende Situation da links auf der Schiene. Ich glaube, er hat in der Liga jetzt fünf Tore, acht Vorlagen. Ich weiß, er ist kein klassischer Verteidiger, keine Frage. Aber wirklich offensiv herausragend. Die Bälle von Di Marco kennen wir ja seinen linken Fuß. Jetzt ist er, Quivo hat ihn noch mal ein bisschen offensiver mit reingebracht. Er hat noch mehr Ballkontakte im gegnerischen Strafraum. Also weiterhin eine brutale offensive Waffe. Und da kommen wir jetzt eben auf Quivo, weil er halt eben– und das ist meiner Meinung nach die größte Qualität, die wir jetzt zuzuschreiben haben– er hat es geschafft, den Kreis der Spieler, die er mit reinholt, deutlich zu erweitern. Also bei Simonin Sagi war es ja meistens so, der hatte so seine 14, 15 Mann, mit denen ist er durchgezogen, mit denen ist er zwei Mal in drei Jahren ins Champions League-Finale gekommen. Aber die waren dann halt auch oft am Ende der Saison einfach platt mit den vielen Spielen, was wir ja perfekt am Ende der vergangenen Saison gesehen haben, mit dem Champions League-Finale, mit der vergebenen Meisterschaft dann am letzten Spieltag. Und Quivo hat es von Anfang an geschafft, einfach diesen Kreis auf Spieler, denen er vertraut und die er belasten kann, auf 17, 18, 19 zu erweitern. Und das allerbeste Beispiel ist da zum Beispiel der zentrale Mittelfeld. Also wenn Simone, Sage und Inter jetzt ein paar denken, dann denken die logisch zurecht an Cialanolo, Barrella, Miquetarian. Das waren die drei, die immer gespielt haben in wichtigen Spielen. Punkt. Jetzt zum Beispiel zuletzt, Cialanolo ist gerade ein bisschen verletzt, Barrella hat die letzten zwei Spiele gefehlt. Jetzt gab es ein, zwei– zuletzt gab es ein Ligaspiel, da hat keiner der drei gespielt. Kein einziger. Da hat dann Cielinski gespielt, der seit Wochen in richtig guter Verfassung ist. Das ist zum Beispiel einer von denen, die Kivo mit rein geholt hat. Der war unter Simonin Sagi Reiner, Ergänzungsspieler. Klar, der hatte auch immer wieder physische Probleme, ist schwer angekommen, aber der war einfach nicht im Rhythmus. Und Cielinski funktioniert jetzt wunderbar. Dazu hast du mit Sučić wieder einen neuen Jungen, der ein bisschen frische Energie reingebracht hat. Also Pio Zpozitor ist 20, Boni ist 22, Sučić ist, glaube ich, 23. Das war ja auch ein Thema bei Inter, dass du da durchaus ein bisschen extern frische Luft reinbringst. Sučić wunderbar in der Rotation drin spielt. Viel hat zum Beispiel auch zuletzt in der Champions League gegen Arsenal das Tor gemacht. Das ist für mich so das größte Neue. Dann müssen wir logisch über Akanji sprechen. Das war logisch ein grandioser Transfer, den von City im Sommer zu holen. Der gibt dahinten Stabilität. Ich glaube, Uli korrigiert mich gerne, aber ich glaube, der ist erstmal ausgeliehen und dann ist die Kaufoption bei 15 Millionen Euro. Da muss ich sagen, das ist halt wieder mal Marotta Masterclass, weil einen von der Qualität von Akanji für 15 Millionen am Ende zu kriegen, würde ich mal sagen, da kannst du einen fetten grünen Haken dahinter machen mit der Erfahrung und mit der Qualität. Und Akanji ist eben auch ein Thema, um jetzt kurz ins Taktische reinzukommen. Er hat logisch nicht– er hat verstanden, Kibo, dass das eine Mannschaft ist, die funktioniert, die im Kern ja auch zusammengeblieben ist, also wäre er dumm gewesen, da alles umzuwerfen. Aber er hat halt so Nuancen angepasst. Und eine Nuance, die jetzt ganz klar rauskommt, ist, sie stehen deutlich höher. Also die Abwehrlinie steht 10, teilweise 12 Meter höher. Sie sind deutlich aggressiver im Gegenpressing, gehen vorne drauf. In der Serie A ist Inter mittlerweile die Mannschaft mit den meisten Ballgewinnen im letzten Spielfeldtrittel. Also vor zum Beispiel Atalanta, vor Gasperini's Roma. Also in Italien gibt es durchaus zwei, drei Trainer und Mannschaften, die dafür stehen, schon seit Jahren. Und Kiwu hat diese Schärfe jetzt sofort reingebracht. Also sie schieben durch, sie verkürzen das Feld. Und da ist eben Akanji und auch Bissek, der jetzt auch wieder eine noch größere Rolle hat, sind da eben zentral, weil wenn du hoch verteidigst, hast du manchmal auch viel Raum hinter dir zu verteidigen. Und da brauchst du logisch auch Tempo. Und da bist du mit Bissek, mit Akanji und auch mit Bastoni richtig gut aufgestellt. Also der erfahrene Acerbi ist schon immer wieder mit dabei, gerade wenn es gegen physisch Störke Neuner geht. Da ist er weiterhin, da hat er Qualität. Aber jetzt über die Saison gesehen, ist Bissek da wirklich eigentlich fest in dieser Dreierkette drin und steht auch so ein bisschen für diesen neuen Stil. Also höher stehen, mutiger im Gegend, pressig, mehr hohe Ballgewinne, manchmal auch mehr Vertikalität. Also das ist schon auch eine Handschrift von Kiwo, die man jetzt schon erkennen kann. Und was glaubst du, wie weit das führen kann? Also in der Liga sieht es sehr, sehr gut aus. In der Champions League geht es in der Zwischenrunde gegen Glimt. Da musste natürlich vorbei cruisen als Inter. Aber man hatte ja schon, also in der Vergangenheit haben wir es häufiger gesehen, dass jemand, der es ins Finale geschafft hat, der aber verloren hat, es dann relativ schnell noch mal geschafft hat, ins Finale zu kommen. Und gerade bei Inter, glaube ich, gibt es da ja schon, da gibt es ja was wettzumachen, weil einfach die Art der Niederlage keine schöne war.
Traust du es dir zu?
Ja, also das ist jetzt schon weiter. Ich würde erst mal so anfangen, ich bin ein Verfechter davon. Ich weiß, ich glaube, ich habe es schon zwei, dreimal gesagt. Ich finde, wenn du als Inter in den letzten drei Jahren schon zweimal im Champions League-Finale warst, dann ist das erst mal schon mehr als respektabel. Weil überhaupt dahin kommen als Inter, also ich vergleiche es immer so, ich glaube, wenn wir im Sommer ein Ranking machen würden in der Champions League, wer sind die Top 7, 8 Contender, dann glaube ich, kommt nicht unbedingt Inter. Weil dann kommen erst mal die Reals, die Barsers, die Citys, die Arsenals, die Bayern, die PSG. Und dass da Inter einfach zweimal da war, finde ich schon mal höchst respektabel. Logisch, du stehst am Ende mit leeren Händen da. Aber jetzt noch mal zu verlangen, dass sie dieses Jahr wieder ins Finale kommen, das finde ich ein bisschen viel. Was ich aber glaube, sie sind jetzt wieder in Playoffs oder im KO-Modus unangenehm. Weil sie kennen diesen Modus, sie haben sich da die letzten Jahre auch wohl gefühlt. 180 Minuten bedeutet auch immer 90, mindestens 90 in San Siro. Das ist ein Faktor. Deswegen glaube ich, die Gruppenphase ist noch gar nicht so ihr Ding. Ich glaube schon, dass die jetzt eben, wie gesagt, wenn sie Bodo Glimp rausnehmen sollten, dass sie danach, ich glaube, dass wenige gerne gegen sie spielen werden, auch von den großen Namen. Und dann, ja, muss man halt schauen, wenn du dann kriegen kannst. Aber ich traue ihnen schon zu, dass sie wieder sehr, sehr, sehr unangenehm sind. Weil, eben wie Cialanolo kurz angesprochen, der fehlt jetzt echt öfter schon, hat man nicht so gemerkt. Und einer, der wirklich schon seit Monaten fehlt, ist Dumfries. Also sie ziehen durch ohne Dumfries. Und Dumfries, glaube ich, haben alle noch in Erinnerung, dass es ein sehr wichtiger Faktor der Inter-Mannschaft der letzten Jahre war. Und der soll jetzt wohl Ende Februar wieder zurückkommen. Also es könnte so passen, wenn dann Inter dann wirklich ins Achtelfinale geht, dass sie dann Dumfries auch wieder haben. Weil, das muss man schon sagen, das Interspiel war immer schon linkslastig mit die Marco und Pastoni. Aber im Moment, um den Kreis wieder zu Olympique Marseille von vorhin zu schließen, spielt da Luis Henrique, den sie im Sommer da geholt haben. Und der spielt, Punkt. Also der macht keine großen Fehler, aber der ist kein Faktor. Offensiv wirklich noch gar nicht in Erscheinung getreten. Und wenn da Dumfries zurückkommen sollte, dann hast du logisch wieder rechts die Atletik und Dynamik von Dumfries, links die spielerische Qualität von die Marco und Pastoni. Also dann würde ich auch sagen, dann bist du auch in den K.o.-Spielen dann einfach noch mal schwerer auszurechnen. Aber jetzt noch mal ein Finale zu verlangen. Ich hab's ja nicht verlangt, dass er nicht so ein deutscher Podcast erfordert. Nein, schon klar. Ich meinte nur, also klar stehen da 4, 5, 6 glaube ich andere deutlich davor auf der Liste. Aber lass Inter dann zweimal Hin- und Rückspiel spielen. Und Jan Sommer, ist er noch ein bisschen gewachsen? Also Jan Sommer, gut. Das finde ich auch ein sehr gutes Thema. Also Sommer hatte zuletzt ein paar Patzer. Hat man wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen. Gab es jetzt auch die eine Szene in der Liga, wo er aus dem Strafraum rauskommt, ein Gegner den Ball in den Fuß spielt und der trifft aus 25 Metern. Aber auch da sieht man, finde ich, so ein bisschen die Ruhe, die Inter ausstrahlt. Also Kiwo hat den immer total in den Rücken gestärkt. Ich glaube gegen Dortmund war er nicht schlecht, wenn ich mich noch in Erinnerung habe. Also das sieht man, die sind tiefenentspannt. Also klar, der hatte diese Wackler drin. Ganz kurz, sein Vertrag läuft im Sommer aus. Also es deutet jetzt auch wirklich alles drauf hin, dass dann Inter da einen neuen Schritt macht. Aber nicht, weil man unzufrieden ist oder was weiß ich, sondern ich glaube, das Kapitel wird jetzt wahrscheinlich zu Ende gehen. Jan Sommer ist 37 Jahre alt. Aber auch das, wie gesagt, finde ich, spricht eher dafür, wie Inter auch das handelt. Also da gab es keine Nervosität, keine Oh mein Gott, Jan Sommer macht jetzt zwei Fehler, was machen wir jetzt? Sondern er hat die volle Rückendeckung und dementsprechend. Also es ist wirklich Ruhe da bei Inter. Sie wissen, was sie können und dementsprechend. In der Liga für mich ganz klar der Favorit. Napoli hatten wir jetzt zuletzt, die haben andere Probleme. Juve kommen danach noch kurz. Die sind jetzt auf einem guten Weg, aber die sind einfach zu weit weg. Und dementsprechend läuft es jetzt darauf aus, ob Milan dranbleiben kann oder ob Napoli vielleicht jetzt, wo sie aus der Champions League raus sind, auch noch mal eine kleine Serie starten können. Man weiß es ja nie. Aber in der Liga sind sie ganz klar die Eins. Und Champions League, mal schauen, was im K.o.-Modus kommt. Aber vielleicht ganz gut, dass wir mal über Kibo gesprochen haben, weil der jetzt schon vieles Gutes in Bewegung gesetzt hat. Aber wirklich, das war echt überfällig. Ich habe irgendwann mal die Torbilanz von Inter gesehen und dachte mir so, eigentlich irre, dass wir da noch nicht so ausführlicher drüber gesprochen haben. Haben wir jetzt nachgeholt? Jetzt wollen wir noch ein bisschen schneller durch die Ligen durchgehen. Uli, wenn du magst, dann schauen wir nochmal in die Premier League. Newcastle wäre da zum Beispiel noch ein Thema. Auf Rang 11 mit 33 Punkten. Damit liegt man so ziemlich schön in der Mitte. Aber es sind halt auch schon ganz schön viele Punkte nach oben. Was läuft denn da falsch? Übrigens ganz schön, also für den Monk in mir, mir gefällt das sehr.
9 Siege, 6 Unentschieden, 9 Niederlagen, 33 geschossene Tore, 33 kassierte Tore, 33 Punkte, Rang 11.
Also ich... Bitte abweifen.
Fehlen 3 Unentschieden, sorry. Dann wär's perfekt, ne?
Ja.
Dann hätten wir eine andere Punktzahl.
Ja, genau. Okay.
Schön, gut, dass du mich hast, sonst wär dir das auch nie aufgefallen. Ja, wenn ich ehrlich bin, mehr Fragen als Antworten bei Newcastle. Vorneweg, wie vor zwei Jahren, letztes Jahr, waren sie einigermaßen verschont, aber wie vor zwei Jahren, epidemischste Verletzungs-Sorgen bei Newcastle. Keine großartigen Manöver, um sich zu rühren, aufgrund der PSA-Regelungen, Nachhaltigkeitsregelungen in der Premier League. Das heißt, die hätten mindestens einen Verteidiger brauchen können und einen Stürmer oder vielleicht sogar zwei Stürmer, brauchen einen Mittelfeldspieler unbedingt und dringend. Sie konnten aber nichts tun jetzt in diesem Winter schon wieder. Zumindest von all dem, was man hört, haben sie sich nicht getraut, weil ja niemand so richtig zu 100 Prozent einschätzen kann, was denn dann wie wo bewertet wird seitens der Premier League hinsichtlich dieser PSA-Regelungen, sodass sie jetzt lieber kein Risiko gegangen sind. Das Problem ist nur, das tun sie schon seit zweieinhalb Jahren nicht. Also die de facto tiefsten Taschen, wahrscheinlich der gesamten Welt, was einen Fußballverein betrifft, die sind halt noch nie zum Tragen gekommen. Außer vielleicht ist das die Ausnahme, einmal ganz kurz im Sommer, da haben sie sich aber rein weiße Körbe eingefangen und haben dann am Ende ganz klassisch Overspending betrieben mit Woltemade, mit Vissar und wie sie alle heißen, nachdem sie vorher bei Eketi Key zu lange gebraucht haben, der dann noch zu Liverpool gegangen ist und so weiter. Das führt dazu, dass Eddie Hauder einen Kader hat mit 13, 14 Mann und wenn man insgesamt dann minimum 55 Pflichtspiel dazu absolviert hat, die es jetzt sein werden mit diesen zwei Extraspielen in der Champions League. Seit gestern sind sie heraus im EFL Cup, aber da haben sie auch fast bis Ende gespielt. Nur das Finale dann am Ende nicht, das hätten sie sicherlich ganz gerne noch mitgenommen, ist das ein Teil der Erklärung. Der andere ist, dass Isak nicht ersetzt werden konnte, weder von Vissar noch von Woltemade. Beide zusammen gab es sekundenweise, wenn überhaupt in der Premier League. Beide für sich funktionieren nicht. Um den Schlenker einmal kurz zu machen, soll man sich ja nicht so ärgern lassen von Berichterstattung in Deutschland. Aber das hat mich mitunter geärgert, dass bei Florian Wirtz alles bodenlos war und bei Woltemade war alles absolute Weltklasse.
Er war beknickt. Er hatte einen Spitzennamen. Das reicht schon, dass deutsche Medien einfach davon überzeugt sind, dass er super ankommt, weil er schon einen Spitzennamen gekriegt hat.
Bis heute übrigens. Ich habe es jetzt am vergangenen Wochenende einmal kurz thematisiert. Genau das in einem Spiel für Newcastle. Dann sind wenigstens zwei, drei Medien mit aufgesprungen. Gestern habe ich noch einmal thematisiert, dass sich in England– also das entwickelt sich langsam zu Hass gegen Woltemade. Das ist halt einfach insofern logisch, weil er der Rekordtransfer ist. Und halt seit, ich glaube, in den letzten 15 Spielen nur einmal getroffen hat. Das war ein Doppelpack gegen Chelsea. Vielleicht sind sogar 16 Spiele inzwischen. Kann sein, dass ich es mixe. Auf jeden Fall schon lange nicht mehr. Und die spielerischen Leistungen sind halt gar nicht.
Der deutsche All war das.
Genau, ganz genau. Und jetzt wird es richtig hässlich. Ein ehemaliger Club-Boss hat den richtig zu saugemacht. Und jetzt geht es los in England. Und der ist weder so überragend gewesen, noch war wir zu mies. Und es ist auch jetzt nicht alles so mies bei Woltemade. Sondern der hatte einfach eine wahnsinnig effiziente Phase zu Beginn der Saison, wo halt alles reingefallen ist, was ihm irgendwie vor den Kopf oder vor den Fuß gekommen ist. Also er hatte eine Chancenverwertung wirklich von über 50 Prozent. Also es war erstaunlich. Und ja, den haben sie nicht ersetzen können. Sie haben aber– und das ist der größere Punkt– sie haben nie gelernt, für ihn zu spielen. Und er macht weiterhin das, was er macht. Er fällt halt wahnsinnig viel ins Mittelfeld. Hat jetzt auch gestern zum Beispiel nicht im Sturmzentrum begonnen. Das ist ja grundsätzlich mal ganz nett. Aber dann brauche ich halt ein Workaround. Und ich dachte, dass man in Langa deshalb holt, damit man sozusagen Tempo um ihn herum hat, damit er fallen kann, das Pressing anziehen kann. Mit Vissar hätte man theoretisch jemanden, mit dem man gegengläusige Bewegungen hätte einstudieren können. Nur ist Vissar erst gar nicht da gewesen, weil er verletzt war. Dann ist er so langsam im Dezember zurückgekommen, aber wirklich nur langsam. Hat dann dreimal getroffen. Generell war so Jahreswende. Da hatten sie immer vier Siege in Folge. Das war okay, aber auch nur okay. Jetzt ist es schon wieder nichts mehr. Jeder Sieg, den sie holen, ist wahnsinnig mühsam, ist alles dramatisch. Das ist dann der finale Punkt, um es einmal rund zu machen. Ohne Bruno Gimaraes– das ist wie gehabt, also hat sich in den letzten drei Jahren gar nichts verändert– sind die einfach eine Klasse schlechter. Die brauchen den im Aufbau oder in der zweiten Phase. Egal, aber sie brauchen ihn jedenfalls. Sandro Tonali hat auch so eine Mini-Krise gehabt. Wobei, die war gar nicht so mini, wenn ich mir für seine Verhältnisse ernsthaft überlege. Es ist keine gute Saison, es wird gerade ein bisschen besser, weil er scheint etwas fleißiger gegen den Ball wiederzuwerden. Das hilft schon mal ein bisschen, aber die absolut genialen Momente sind nicht da. Dazu kam ja jetzt noch, dass seine Repräsentanz, den am Deadline Day total desperat angeboten hat bei Arsenal, obwohl die den gar nicht zahlen können und Newcastle nichts davon wusste. Also es ist auch so atmosphärisch nicht ganz so clever gelöst, auch wenn ich es gerne gesehen hätte, muss ich sagen. Also das fände ich schon nicht unspannend, den bei Arsenal zu haben, aber es ist natürlich ein bisschen ungut, wenn das so läuft. Und jetzt wird halt diskutiert. In England hat Eddie Hau vielleicht sogar zu viel Macht auf dem Transfermarkt. Die haben ja komplett einmal ihre gesamte Administration verändert. Also die hatten zwischenzeitlich gar keine, weder einen Geschäftsführer, noch einen Sportdirektor. Das ist jetzt alles aufgefüllt mit, wie ich finde, auch guten Leuten. Zumindest ist das im Moment so die Einschätzung dessen, aber wieder nichts getan. Da gab es ja noch, wenn du dich erinnerst, Osula und Frankfurt-Gerüchte. Die sind auch wahr. Also Frankfurt hat sich für den interessiert. Es war nur so, dass Newcastle halt wusste, sie können sich, selbst wenn sie ihn verkaufen, ist da einfach nur ein weiterer Körper weg. Und sie können ihn nicht ansatzweise ersetzen. Also in der Premier League bedeutet ja Ersatz für egal, welchen Stürmer, also irgendein Teil des Kaders, 10 bis 15 Millionen. Und sie hätten von Frankfurt nicht mal im Ansatz das zurückbekommen. Und das klickt ja dann auch erst in den Bilanzen etwas später rein, sodass sie nichts hätten tun können. Also haben sie sich entschieden, das nicht zu machen. Komischerweise, in der Abwehr haben sie sich anders entschieden. Da haben sie Jamal Esselsoh abgegeben, der natürlich 0,0 Rolle gespielt hat. Das ist auch so eine Eigenart von Eddie Howe, dass er dann im Ende auch nur mit 13, 14 Leuten geht. Aber man merkt denen halt, diese ganzen Spiele zu leisten haben, brutal an, wie müde sie sind. Also keine Frische, das ist wahrscheinlich das richtige Wort. Nicht müde, sondern keine Frische.
Ganz kurz, Tonale, weil Tonale ist echt spannend. Ich finde auch, der ist total müde. Das sieht man denen an. Du sagst es ja, die haben ja nicht nur die vielen Premier League und Cup-Spiele, die haben ja auch nur die Champions League. Wenn du da mit 13, 14 Mann gehst, mit der Intensität, das sieht man Tonale an. Also Tonale ist wirklich spannend. Diese Nummer am Ende mit Arsenal habe ich auch nicht ganz verstanden. Ich sage nur Richtung Sommer. Juve wird sehr viel probieren bei Tonale. Also Juve hat ihn jetzt so ein bisschen auserkurren. Das wäre der eine riesen Transfer, den sie probieren. Keine Ahnung, logisch, wie seine Gedanken das sind. Vielleicht will er auch in der Premier League bleiben. Aber Tonale wird spannend werden.
Also mein Tipp ist, es hängt extrem mit dem Auskommen zusammen. Max hat ja vorher gesagt, es reißt langsam ab. Es ist aber immer noch alles okay. Wir vermuten ja, dass Platz 5 reichen würde für die Champions League-Qualifikation. Minus 7, glaube ich, sind es, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Das ist machbar. Zumal die anderen ja auch kein Stück stabil sind, die da runter rumschwirren. Das ist schon machbar, aber ich kann mir schwer vorstellen, dass der... Das ist ja immer das Problem. Die machen ja seit Jahren das Gleiche. Die haben dann so einzelne europäische Nächte, wo du denkst, yes, jetzt habe ich die Wahrheit gesehen. Paris Umstellung auf Fünferkette war echt gut. Gestern haben sie auf Fünferkette gespielt. Ich habe selten was Schlechteres gesehen. Also ohne Witz, das war für ihre Verhältnisse, die stellen ja in der Theorie, den sage ich immer, und ich bin da auch fest davon überzeugt, den besten mittleren Block des Landes. Weil das ist ja körperlich... Das gehört ja verboten, was die da rumstehen haben. Und wenn die das ordentlich mit Intensität füllen, dieses Eddie-Hausche-System da, dann ist das halt super schwierig zu knacken. Also gestern, das war Wahnsinn, wie die sich haben auskontrollen lassen. Das hat er dann auch umgestellt zur Pause, hat aber nur nichts mehr gebracht, aber das hängt vermutlich mit der Müdigkeit zusammen. Mentaler Art, wie auch immer, I don't know, aber es gibt sie, diese Leistungen. Die gibt es in jeder Champions-League-Saison 2, 3, wo du denkst, ja, das ist es. Und die gibt es auch in der Premier League manchmal, diese Leistungen. Und dann kommt aber wieder so ein Geschlampe mit dazu, dass sie halt einfach in dieser Saison, jetzt gerade in der Phase, auch wieder extrem haben. Also für ihre Verhältnisse extrem. Vergangenes Saison war es oft so, dass sie teilweise die Ergebnisse geholt haben. Leistungen waren nicht so gut. Jetzt war es in der Saison eine Zeit lang so, dass die Leistungen eigentlich okay waren. Zunächst die Ergebnisse nur nicht. Und jetzt ist leistungstechnisch auch alles weg. Und dann wird es auch hässlich, glaube ich, da. Also das wird jetzt dann langsam, wenn es so weitergeht, noch zwei, drei Spiele. Und dann wird es ungut.
Und dann kommt zu diesem eh schon sehr müden Kader noch das Auslösungsglück, dass man nach Karabak darf. Und zwischendurch dann nochmal auswärts bei City spielen, gegen die man ja jetzt eben gerade dieses 1 zu 3 hatte im Pokal. Also ja, das wird echt nochmal interessant bei Newcastle. Jetzt waren wir doch ein bisschen länger hier noch im Thema drin. Aber gab ja auch wirklich viel zu erzählen. Jakob, was gibt es denn noch aus der Ligue 1 zu erzählen?
Ja, da habe ich mal was Positives noch mitgebracht. Und zwar eine echte Underdog-Story eines Aufsteigers. In der letzten Folge hatten wir über Paris FC gesprochen, bei denen das ja überhaupt nicht zutrifft. Und jetzt haben wir aber mit dem FC Lorient ja zumindest eine deutlich eher eine Underdog-Story. Denn die haben jetzt auch im Sommer nicht viel ausgegeben, haben, glaube ich, gut zwei Millionen an neuen Transfers investiert. Und das sah auch erst zu Saisonstart so aus, als würden sie sich ganz schön schwer tun. Sie haben die ersten Punkte eigentlich nur geholt, wenn der Gegner in Unterzahl war. Das war so ein Lauf, der ganz faszinierend war. Sie haben das erste Mal gewonnen in Gleichzahl ein Spiel am 30.11. damals gegen Nizza. Also hat dann wirklich relativ lange gedauert. Da war unter anderem auch dieses Freak-Spiel dabei. Da hatten wir, glaube ich, auch mal darüber geredet, wo es da drinnen in den ersten 20 Minuten schon zwei rote Karten gekriegt hatte und Lurion das dann ausgenutzt hat. Man muss sagen, dahingehend haben sie dann ihre Chancen auch super genutzt, dass sie aus diesen Überzahlen immer echt viel auch gemacht haben. Und jetzt sind sie aber tatsächlich seit dem 2. November auch ungeschlagen, und zwar in allen Wettbewerben. Also auch im Pokal haben sie gestern gegen Paris FC gewonnen, stehen da jetzt im Viertelfinale. Damals haben sie gegen Lens 0 zu 3 verloren in der Liga. Und das führt jetzt dazu, dass man sie eigentlich so als klaren Abstiegskandidaten schon auf den Schirm hatte. Jetzt stehen sie aber auf Platz 9, haben 14 Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz 16. Und bei dem Tempo, was die unteren drei, Nond, Oxair und Mess vorlegen, kann man nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen, dass es da nochmal eng werden dürfte. Zumal, also die Form spricht natürlich für Lorient. Aber selbst wenn sie jetzt nur noch fünf Punkte holen oder so in den letzten 14 Spielen, sollte das schon reichen. Also kann man, glaube ich, davon ausgehen, dass sie den Klassen halt definitiv jetzt eingetütet haben. Gut, es gibt immer wieder besondere Geschichten. Ich glaubte aber nicht dran. Und momentan haben sie sogar auch nur, je nachdem, worauf es letztendlich hinausläuft, welche Plätze für Europa reichen, nur zwei bis drei Punkte Rückstand auf die europäischen Plätze. Das wiederum ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen zu hoch gegriffen. Das kann ich mir nicht unbedingt vorstellen, dass das jetzt so anhalten wird, denn sie haben auch so einen kleinen Lauf. Da steht zum Beispiel auch Mittelstürmer Bamba Dieng ziemlich sinnbildlich für, der jetzt in den letzten vier Spielen drei Tore gemacht hat, dann im Pokal auch noch fünf Mal getroffen hat, in den letzten drei Pokalspielen. Also da jetzt wirklich plötzlich acht Tore in den letzten Wochen geschossen hat, nachdem er vorher gar keine Rolle gespielt hat. In der letzten Saison war er auch an Angé verliehen, hat da also auch schon League 1 gespielt, als Lorient hochgekommen ist. Und der kam jetzt so ein bisschen wie Phoenix aus der Asche, hatte in den letzten Jahren auch immer Verletzungsprobleme, ist jetzt so ein bisschen der Mann der Stunde bei dem Team. Und man muss auch dazu sagen, dass sie im Sommer in der Offensive ihren zentralen Spieler verloren haben mit Eli Junior-Cruppi, der ja jetzt auch bei Bournemouth durchaus performt in der Premier League, war letzte Saison in der Ligue 2 mit 22 Toren der Torschützenkönig, war allerdings schon nur noch ausgeliehen von Bournemouth, denn das ist dann wieder der Punkt, weswegen ich auch in der Einleitung ganz kurz gestockt habe, denn auch Lorient ist Teil eines Vulti-Club-Ownerships. Sie gehören zur Black Knight Group mit Bournemouth zusammen und dementsprechend hatten sie dann Gruppi, der ist eigentlich, ja, kommt schon von Lorient. Also es war nicht so, dass sie den von Bournemouth ausgeliehen hatten, aber der ist dann halt letztes Frühjahr von Bournemouth auch offiziell gekauft worden für 13 Millionen und durfte dann aber bis zum Sommer noch bleiben, sie also in die erste Liga schießen. Aber dafür, jetzt fernab der ganzen Diskussionen darum, die wir ja hier auch immer wieder gerne führen, finde ich schon bemerkenswert, dass sie halt nicht, also es ist nicht so wie bei Straßburg, dass jetzt die Black Knight Football Group sagt, okay, wir geben euch jetzt tonnenweise Geld. Ich hatte es ja gerade gesagt, sie haben 2 Millionen ausgegeben im Sommer. Und dann auch Groupie eigentlich nicht wirklich ersetzt, sondern das halt viel von innen heraus gemacht, mit Spielern aus der eigenen Jugend durchaus. Also zum Beispiel im Sturm dann Sambu Sumano, der bevor die Jäger jetzt so explodiert ist, auch eine gewisse Rolle gespielt hat. Dann auf jeden Fall bemerkenswert Pablo Pagis, ein 23-Jähriger, auch aus der eigenen Jugend. Der hat jetzt auch schon 6 Tore gemacht, ist damit in der Liga Lurians bester Spieler. Es ist so ein offensiver Mittelfeldspieler, Außenspieler, der auch einen echt guten Schuss hat. Also den finde ich echt bemerkenswert. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Name, auf den man mal ein Auge haben kann. Ist auch beidfüßig, finde ich ein sehr interessanter Spieler. Dann haben sie auf der linken Schiene, also sie spielen immer so ein 3-4-3. Da ist mit Arsène Kouassi ein ivorischer linker Verteidiger, der jetzt gegen Nantes am letzten Spieltag, auch in der Schlussphase ein schönes Freistoß-Tor geschossen hat. Den haben sie im Sommer für eine 1 Million aus der zweiten Liga von Ajaxio geholt. Der könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass der im Sommer jetzt auch für eine zweistellige Summe schon wieder weggeht. Ist erst 21, zeigt da aber richtig gute Leistungen. Und so haben sie da echt ein paar interessante Spieler rund um Laurent Abagel. Das ist so das Urgestein und der Kapitän des Vereins im zentralen Mittelfeld. Eine der Säulen im Tor haben sie mit Yvonne Vogo, auch einen alten Bekannten, der ja bei Leipzig mal eine Zeit lang, zumindest unter Vertragsstand, hat da ja, glaube ich, nicht so viel gespielt. Aber der ist sozusagen vielleicht jetzt aus der Sicht, wenn man nicht so viel auf die Liga 1 guckt, so das Gesicht der auch relativ soliden Defensive. Also sie lassen, glaube ich, die siebt wenigsten Schüsse der Liga zu, stehen da also gut dabei, haben eine durchaus solide Abwehr. Also Olivier Pantaloni, der Coach, hat da echt was Gutes geformt. Da denkt man dann ja auch schnell dran, ob da jetzt vielleicht auf der Trainerbank, so der die nächste heiße Aktie sitzt. Das würde ich jetzt bei Olivier Pantaloni nicht unbedingt behaupten wollen. Der ist auch schon 59, was er jetzt auch auf dem Trainermarkt dann nicht unbedingt zumindest mehr das Talentalter ist. Der war auch ganz lange auf Corsica bei Ajaxio und war da Trainer und hat dann aber in der letzten Saison auch den Aufstieg schon zu verantworten gehabt bei Lurion, den sie ja auch vor dem finanzkräftigeren Paris FC geschafft haben. Also das ist auf jeden Fall eine der Positivgeschichten jetzt momentan. Und wenn es so weitergeht, auch definitiv der Saison in Frankreich.
Fantastisch, der FC Lurion. Vergessen wir mal das ganze Multi-Club-Ownership, weil du hast ja recht, es sieht nicht so viel aus.
Aber der Name ist wenigstens geil, Black Knight Football Group, da kann ich... Wenigstens das.
Ja, das stimmt, ja.
Ja, okay, gut, geben wir ihn, geben wir ihn. Gut, das ist der Blick.
Und ich habe noch einen Familienbezug, denn das haben wir auch gerne. Denn wir haben ja, glaube ich, irgendwann dieses Jahr auch schon über Regis Le Brice gesprochen und der Neffe von ihm spielt bei Lorient, Theo Le Brice.
Das wäre das Teil, was der Onkel kann, dann not bad.
Genau.
Okay, sehr gut. Das war der Blick nach Frankreich. Und dann blicken wir jetzt auf La Liga. Alex, was hast du uns da noch mitgebracht?
Ja, im Endeffekt zwei Themen, zwei kleine Themen, die Fabi Pakulac schon vor zwei Wochen hier im Rasenfunk besprochen hat. Aber die sind halt weiterhin aktuell bzw. mit so neun Turns. Das eine ist natürlich die Lage bei Real Madrid und die andere ist die persönliche Lage von Ters Degen. Ich weiß nicht, welche du als erstes besprechen willst.
Lass mal mit Ters Degen anfangen, weil das auch so die größeren Schlagzeilen hier gezogen hat. Und weil ich ja weiß, dass du da ja auch den Barca-Hintergrund hast. Wie wird denn das beim FC Barcelona aufgefasst, dass er jetzt schon wieder lange wegen einer Verletzung ausfällt? Muss man letztlich sagen, alles richtig gemacht aus Barca-Sicht jetzt?
Erstens, ja, wahrscheinlich das. Das klingt sehr makaber, aber schwere Muskelverletzungen, also Rupatur, die muss er operativ jetzt entfernen lassen oder muss sich operieren lassen. Er hat übrigens während wir hier recorden, glaube ich, auf Social Media einen Post publiziert, wo er sich an die Fans von Girona wendet und sagte, er entscheidet sich für die OP und fällt damit monatelang aus. Also, sagt er selber. Also, die Rede ist von mindestens zwei Monaten oder voraussichtlich zwei Monaten, im Idealfall vielleicht auch bis zu drei Monaten. Und jetzt timetable-mäßig, wir haben jetzt Anfang Februar, im Sommer ist ein größeres Event, da wäre er gerne dabei. Auch deswegen ist er ja dahin gewechselt zu Girona. Und das ist jetzt erst recht mit großen Fragezeichen versehen. Also, für ihn persönlich natürlich fatal, ganz, ganz tragisch und schlimm. Dass es sich vor allem nicht nur irgendwie den Oberschenkel ein bisschen reißt, sondern drei Wochen, mein Gott. Sondern wirklich, wir reden von zwei Monaten plus, die er da ausfällt. Und ja, ganz persönlich sehr, sehr schlimm für ihn, finde ich. Für Deutschland wahrscheinlich auch nicht die optimal News, meiner Meinung nach, aus Barcelonersicht, um deine Frage zu beantworten. Ja, Retrospektiv im Sommer, alles richtig gemacht durch Joan Garcia's Kauf und durch den Abgang von Tastegen, also durch das Rausgeleiten aus dem Verein, so nenne ich es mal. Ja.
Es ist schon einfach, es ist schon, also das hat ja schon Marco Reus Dimensionen bei Tastegen. So ein bisschen anders, weil er halt lange hinter Manuel Neuer stand, aber es ist einfach bitter. Aber nehmt ihr das auch so wahr, dass bei euch in den Ligen so manches Thema ein bisschen mehr Temperatur hat, einfach weil es jetzt diese letzten Monate vor der WM sind. Also ich habe zum Beispiel gestern Werder Bremen Schwerpunkt aufgenommen, da ging es um Marco Friedl, der ein bisschen gestänkert hat gegen Horst Steffen. Und da hieß es dann auch nicht so unrecht, naja, der will halt zur WM und der kommt nur als Innenverteidiger zur WM. Da kann er nicht links Verteidiger spielen und deswegen hat er sich beschwert, dass er links Verteidiger spielen muss. Ist das bei euch Uli in den Ligen auch so, dass man so das Gefühl hat, okay, das heizt zu manchen Konflikten noch mal ein bisschen auf?
Ja, logisch. Auch bei den Transfers glaube ich ganz häufig genau um das Thema, dass Einzelne sich noch ins Schaufenster stellen wollten und dass die Fenster aufgehen, finde ich schon auch.
Ja, in Italien ähnlich hat man ja auch die Namen. Also Raspadore hat man gerade ganz klar. Füllkrug hat man ja auch, hat ja Marius letztes Mal darüber gesprochen. Ja, geht es jetzt glaube ich für viele drum, in den nächsten Monaten Eigenwerbung zu betreiben, um dann im Sommer auch Fußball spielen zu können auf einer großen Bühne. Ja, mal gucken, wie wir da noch darüber berichten. Jakob, Ligue 1 wahrscheinlich ähnliches Bild.
Ja, ein paar, die nicht gewechselt sind, deswegen ein paar, die gekommen sind in die Liga und deswegen um ein bisschen Spielpraxis zu sammeln, die sie sonst nirgendwo kriegen. Also, wird schon eine Rolle gespielt haben.
Ja, in Spanien betrifft das Max übrigens den Namen, den ich gerade gedroppt habe, also den Tastin Konkurrenten, Ex-Konkurrenten, Juan Garcia, spielt eine herausragende Saison und ist aber nicht mal unter dem Top 3 der spanischen Torhüter. Und das ist ja schon nicht nur ein Kuriosum oder falsch, kann man nennen, wie man möchte, aber beschäftigt tatsächlich die Medien stark. Also, da gab es wirklich sehr, sehr viele Berichte und Meinungen. Da gibt es ja Radiosender, die noch und nöchig ihre Sendung füllen müssen. Und da wurden wirklich viel– was heißt Stimmung– gemacht, will ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber es ging viel in die Richtung. Schau mal, wie gut er ist. Und für Luis de la Fuente, der Nationaltorhüter, ist er nicht mal einer der drei besten. Weil da sind wir ja schon beim Thema, gerade bei den Torhütern, ist eine besondere Position. Da willst du auch deine klare Nummer eins, die willst du nicht enteiern, die willst du nicht hinterfragen. Und dann der zweite und dritte müssen ja eher Teamplayer sein und müssen ja gar nicht die Besten sein. Da müssen halt einfach nur gut im Kader funktionieren oder im Dressing-Room und das willst du, das Thema willst du dir ungern aufmachen, wenn du da eine gute Kombi hast. Aber das Thema wird aufgemacht, weil Joan Garcia so dermaßen stark ist und Unai Simón, die eigentlich klare Nummer eins, nicht so sonderlich stark ist. Also in Spanien ist das das Thema Nummer eins in den letzten Monaten tatsächlich, die Torhüterposition.
Ja, könnte man ja auch einfach ein bisschen Temperatur rausnehmen, indem man sagt, komm, wir boykottieren einfach alle. Ich ruf mal Bernd Neuendorf an. Vielleicht will er sich umentscheiden. Vielleicht ist jetzt doch die Zeit, darüber zu reden. Aber vielleicht reden wir da mal in einer anderen Sendung drüber, ob es da Diskussionen auch in anderen Ländern gibt. Schauen wir mal auf Italien nochmal. Christian, was hast du uns noch mitgebracht? Ja, gerne. Reißen wir uns mal kurz an. Das ist dann sicher vielleicht auch mal ein Thema, für das nächste Mal tiefer reinzugehen. Aber Juve ist wieder auf Kurs und das hat sehr viel mit Lucianos Ballette zu tun, der ja eben im November übernommen hat. Und ja, der hat jetzt schon sehr schnell den Schlüssel da gefunden. Also Juve jetzt eigentlich seit Wochen, ja, in richtig guter Verfassung. Ich hatte es ja vorhin schon, für ganz vorne waren sie einfach zu weit weg. Es sind jetzt immer noch zehn Punkte auf Inter, weil Inter ja auch den großen Rhythmus fährt. Aber sie sind jetzt logisch wieder voll im Rennen um die Champions League. Sie sind auch an Napoli dran. Milan ist ja auch nicht so weit weg. Also, ich wollte es nur mal kurz anreißen. Schon beeindruckend, wie schnell Spalletti verstanden hat, was diese Mannschaft braucht und was er ihr geben kann. Vielleicht so zwei, drei kleine Appetitanreger. Also er ist auf Viererkette zurück, seit jetzt Bremer wieder da ist. Bremer haben wir öfter schon genannt. Juve mit Bremer ist halt eine andere Stabilität als ohne. Hatte davor wieder wochenlang verletzt gefehlt. Das kann man Igor Tudor logischerweise nicht anhängen, dass er ohne Bremer gespielt hat. Aber seit Bremer jetzt wieder da ist, ist er auf die Viererkette zurück. Jetzt so 4-2-3-1. Ganz klare Prinzipien. Turam und Locatelli bilden die Doppelsechse. Da hat er wirklich sehr gut gearbeitet, weil, wenn wir uns vielleicht ans Ballett erinnern, sowohl zu Napoli-Zeiten oder auch zu Inter, er hatte immer wirklich so einen klassischen Spielmacher, also Napoli-Lobotka. Bei Inter hat er Brosowicz, da hat er Brosowicz dazu gemacht, zu dem Taktgeber. Und jetzt weder Turam noch Locatelli sind so klassische Regisseure, deswegen den hat er einfach nicht. Und jetzt hat er so ein Workaround gefunden, dass er ohne klassischen Regisseur spielt. Also gerade im Spielaufbau geht viel über außen, jetzt auch über die Viererkette. Du hast Cambiaso, Calullo, die schieben gut an über außen, mit Yildiz und Concesau, die das auf außen unterstützen. Und jetzt haben Turam und Locatelli genau die Rollen bekommen, die sie wirklich am besten ausleben können, nämlich Locatelli ist so der defensive Anker. Der gibt wirklich Stabilität, macht sehr viel gegen den Ball, ja, gibt Balance. Und Turam hat ein paar Wetter weiter nach vorne geschoben, weil Turam halt einfach diese Atletik, diese Dynamik hat, auch mit Ball am Fuß da wirklich mal 20 Meter zu reißen, ist jetzt auch wieder torgefährlicher geworden. Also das nur so als kleines Beispiel dafür, dass Spalletti jetzt nicht plötzlich da fünf neue Leute bekommen hat, ist ja klar, konnte er gar nicht, sondern dass er einfach den Kader wunderbar gelesen hat und ja, also ist wirklich beeindruckend. Juwe ist total in Shape und ich bin jetzt auch gespannt in der Champions League. Also wenn es wirklich ins Achtelfinale gehen sollte, das ist schon anders Juwe als noch vor vier Wochen, sechs Wochen. Sie haben Selbstvertrauen, wie gesagt mit Bremer, hinten einfach wieder mit vier oder fünf mal wieder zu Null gespielt. Das beste Beispiel am Wochenende gewinnen sie locker 4-1 in Parma. Bremer ein Doppelpack, packt das sogar mal ein Doppelpack aus. Also jetzt nicht, dass er das müsste, aber Bremer gibt dir eine ganz andere Stabilität. Jonathan David hat wieder funktioniert, jetzt Halbwegs, den hat er auch ein bisschen in Shape bekommen, trifft jetzt häufiger, spielt gut für die Mannschaft. Yildiz war davor schon gut, ist weiter gut. Also ja, gutes Beispiel dafür, dass ein sehr guter Trainer, und ich glaube, Luciano Spalletti, klar können wir jetzt mal dieses Nationalmannschaftsabenteuer ein bisschen in den Klammer setzen. Das war logisch enttäuschend für beide Seiten. Aber was Spalletti, glaube ich, als Klubtrainer in den Jahren davor geleistet hat, sollten noch ein paar auf dem Schirm haben. Und das hat man jetzt halt eben einfach sofort gesehen, seine Intelligenz, auch seine Leadership. Also der Vertrag war erst mal nur bis Sommer sozusagen. Die werden logischerweise verlängern. Und letzte gute Nachricht noch kurz aktuell, bei Yildiz schaut es auch sehr gut aus. Da probieren sie logischerweise auch alles. Der hatte noch einen relativ kleinen Vertrag, sage ich mal. Da sind jetzt alle in Europa dran. Und da hat es jetzt wohl in der letzten Woche große Fortschritte gegeben. Also sind vielleicht nicht mehr weiter weg davon, ihn zu verlängern. Und dann wäre es Yildiz logischerweise auch das Sinnbild. Ja, das ist dann eine neue Juwe-Mannschaft, der ich. Kleiner Blick nach ganz vorne und dann hören wir auf mit Juwe heute. Ich glaube, dass Palette mit Juwe nächstes Jahr auch ganz oben in der Liga angreifen kann. Kenan Girdes ist auch eine der interessantesten Personalien überhaupt der letzten Jahre. Da würde ich so gerne nochmal mit ein paar Leuten beim F3 ansprechen. Ganz ehrlich, das ist einfach.
Aber gut.
So funktioniert es eben manchmal auch. Dann gehen wir nochmal ein letztes Mal durch die Ligen hindurch. Uli, wir schauen nochmal nach England. Wir schauen zu Brentford. Brentford steht auf Rang 7 und ist quasi das Anti-Brighton. Denn während Brighton 10 unentschieden hat, hat Brentford nur 3 unentschieden. Und steht damit immerhin für den Fakt, dass es entweder ein Sieg oder eine Niederlage gibt. Und das ist insofern bemerkenswert, weil die Premier League sich nämlich in einer 0 zu 0-Krise befindet. Man hat jetzt schon so viele 0 zu 0-Spiele gesammelt, wie in der gesamten vorherigen Saison. Was macht den Brentfordt besser als alle anderen Premier Leagueisten?
Sie spielen nicht unentschieden.
Sie verlieren auch mal, gell?
Genau. Wir spielen eine tolle Saison. Also eine, die ich nicht im Ansatz abkommen sehen. Weil nach Thomas Frank dachten wir, okay, da kommt jemand hin. Der ehemalige Standard-Coach war nie Chef-Trainer irgendwo gewesen. Das ist ja in der Premier League noch viel untypischer als irgendwo anders. Weil im Grunde gibt es gar keine Durchlässigkeit von der 2. in die 1. Liga. Keith Andrews ist ein sehr cleverer Kommunikator auch immer schon gewesen. Mitunter auch Experte gewesen. Super Typ. Und die ersten zwei, drei, vier, fünf Spiele der Saison dachte ich, um Gottes willen, die steigen ab. Das ist derart chaotisch gewesen. Und inzwischen ist das ein so super gecoachtes Team. Wie immer natürlich auch einen gewissen Standortvorteil, dass es vergleichsweise ruhig ist. Vor allen Dingen abgeglichen mit den anderen Teams in England. Aber haben mit Igor Thiago einen ganz, also wahrscheinlich den Zielspieler-Prototypen im Moment auf der Welt. Es ist ein physisches, absolutes Monster, aber weit mehr auch. Also Alvin Thonny, da spricht überhaupt gar niemand, jemals auch nur ansatzweise noch darüber. Und wenn ich sie so minimal vergleichen müsste, und das ist wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum sie immer noch mehr gewinnen, als sie dann am Ende verlieren. Das ist ja ein unglaubliches Ergebnis an sich. Sie spielen nicht ganz so aggressiv, wie unter Thomas Frank. Sie sind schneller dabei, sich hinten reinzustellen und haben auch kein Problem, mal 20, 25, 30 Minuten gar nichts zu tun und einfach nur kompakt zu verteidigen. Das ist neu, weil da hatten sie immer Bienen im Hintern. Das tun zu müssen, da haben sie sich manchmal auch etwas naiv was gefangen in den letzten Jahren. Aber das ist ein bisschen besser geworden. Und für mich eine absolut positive Überraschung. Das ist vielleicht sogar die Positivste von allen, weil das habe ich niemals, also gerade nach den ersten Wochen, nie kommen sehen. Nie.
Und im Schatten von Igor Thiago mit dieser wahnsinnigen Bilanz von 16 Toren und einem Assist allein in den Liga spielen, Kevin Schade.
Und die Hälfte Elfmeter, da darf man auch nicht vergessen. Aber trotzdem.
Nimm mir die Freude doch nicht.
Alles gut.
Aber das macht ja dann die 6 Tore von Kevin Schade und die 3 Assists dahinter noch besser. Also der scheint da ja auch eine gute Rolle zu spielen und spielt ja auch immer.
Ja, der hat jetzt am Wochenende rot gesehen, etwas dümmlicher Platzverweis. Aber ansonsten ist der, also der hat nach wie vor das Problem, dass die Chancenverwertung durchaus besser sein dürfte. Aber die Läufe sind ein nicht ganz unwichtiges Element in dem Spiel, dass der da abseits Ballfern sozusagen ganz häufig in die Tiefe sprintet, sich weiterhin auch im Kopfball etwas verbessert und so. Also der spielt an sich eine richtig gute Saison, jahnt ja sowieso immer. Den kriegt man da ja nicht weg, der hat jetzt auch frisch verlängert. Das heißt, beide Deutschen, die da vollkommen unter dem Radar fliegen, werden, wir haben ja vorhin WM gehabt. Ich begrüße inzwischen jedes Mal, wenn ich Brentford mache, Julian Nagelsmann, weil ich fest davon ausgehe, der schaut zu.
Ja, ich finde es aber halt so interessant, weil, also das soll jetzt überhaupt gar kein Disrespect sein, aber bei Chris Führig reißen zwei gute Spiele nach Einwechslung, dass sofort wieder in Deutschland darüber diskutiert wird, muss er mit zur WM. Und Kevin Schade spielt die ganze Zeit bei dem Überraschungsteam der Premier League oder einem der Überraschungsteams der Premier League und wir reden da gar nicht drüber. Also es ist schon interessant.
Ich vermute, dass, also das ist ein bisschen dumm, was ich jetzt sage, aber nur ein bisschen hoffentlich. Ich vermute, dass es so einen ähnlichen Spielertypen in den Planungen Nagelsmanns gibt und deswegen ist vielleicht eine Doppelung da bei Schade und wenn die Chancenverwertung noch minimal besser werden würde oder generell die Effizienz der Output, dann könnte es den Spieler halt raushauen aus dem Kader.
Bitte auf zu weg posten, wer ist der andere Spieler?
Ja, da würde ich jetzt von jedem Tipp hören. Ich glaube, Lyra Zané ist quasi derjenige, der mehr oder weniger im… Entschuldigung. Nur so wie… Ich habe mich gar nicht mit jemandem unterhalten, der da nah dran ist und Nagelsmann setzt der Zané anders ein als der zum Beispiel auf Vereinsebene spielt in der Nationalmannschaft. Das heißt, der hat diese Rolle, also gar nicht mal ein Spielerprofiltypisch, sondern der hat diese, glaube ich, und das ist auch das, was der mir gesagt hat, der wird die Rolle haben, bei einem Turnier für eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten reinzukommen, Tempo zu machen, Gegenspieler zu binden und dead set. Mehr kann ja Schade eigentlich in der Nationalmannschaft realistisch nicht bekommen.
Das klingt aber nach El Mala, oder? Sein Profil. Super Joker mit Speed.
Ja, nur der hat einen 1 gegen 1.
Und El Mala spielt 40 Minuten in der Bundesliga und Kevin Schade spielt alle Minuten in der Premier League. Also wollte ich mich eigentlich auf den Arm nehmen. Der eine ist 24.
Nee, ist okay. Also, ich check es einfach nicht.
Ja, ich check, ich checke es einfach nicht. Also, nee, nee. Nein, ich verstehe es einfach nicht. Ich verstehe es wirklich nicht. Aber ich brauche mir auch nicht darüber diskutieren. Die Bundestrainer dürfen ihre eigenen Entscheidungen treffen. Aber ich darf dann kurz auch mein Unverständnis äußern.
Ich finde es auch schade.
Ohohohoho.
Also, ich lege mich... Ich lege mich aus dem Fest. Ich darf es nicht äußern, nee.
Er hat doch mal gesagt, er heißt Kevin Schade, oder?
Ja, das ist ja bis heute die größte Schade. Also da, ohne Witz, wenn ich den jemals treffe, ne? Was soll das denn? Ich wollte es den Engländern leichter machen. Am Arsch, ey. Der hat uns ein halbes Jahr gekostet, der Mensch.
Wie, warum denn das jetzt? Also, weil sie nennen ihn alle Kevin Schade und ihr müsst jetzt immer korrigieren, oder was?
Nee, es war so, dass der, ich, irgendwie waren da die 11 Freunde, meine ich, involviert, da gab es plötzlich eine riesengroße Story. Also es gibt immer, so muss man es vorher weg sagen, die Premier League ist ja sehr professionell und das meine ich wirklich ganz ernst in dem Fall. Es gibt vor jeder Saison, die werden auch geupdatet, immer Aussprachelisten, wo die Spieler sich selbst aussprechen. Wo sie halt sagen, my name is, was weiß ich. Und komischerweise, aber die Skandinavier sprechen sich immer alle Englisch aus. Also Thomas Frank. Und da habe ich mich mal gefragt, heißen sie Thomas Frank? Nö, Thomas Frank, aber okay, danke. Und da sagt dann in diesem Video, das hat dann irgendwann, glaube ich, Freunde haben es einfach mal entdeckt, die sind auch offen bei YouTube zugänglich, ich bin Kevin Schade. Und dann haben die ein Video gemacht und haben das dann, ich glaube, einen Artikel gemacht und haben das dann auch erklärt, warum das wegen Herkunft dies und das sein könnte, dass der halt Schade heißt. Dann haben wir natürlich alle gesagt, okay krass, Kevin Schade, dann kannst du dir vorstellen, was in meinen DMs los war, ne? Und irgendwie ein halbes Jahr später kommt dann aber doch wieder ein Interview, ja ne, ich wollte es eigentlich nur den Englern dann leichter machen, ich heiße natürlich Schade. Okay, cool, vielen Dank.
Diese Aussprachen gingen auch viral, ne? Gab es auf TikTok und Instagram, wie die sich die Spieler alle erinnern.
Es gab auch mal bei, ich weiß jetzt bis heute nicht, was richtig ist, Seat Kolasinak, haben wir die Bosniener gesagt immer, oder Kolasinac, und der hat in einem, da haben wir einem TheZone-Reporter meinen Auftrag gegeben, frag ihn mal. Und der hat ihn gefragt und er sagt in einem Video 3 verschiedene Aussprachen. Da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, ist auch scheißegal.
Sorry, wollt auch gerade, ich glaub von Mois Ken gibt's auch, wo es sich mal Mois Ken nennt und dann heißt es sich Mois Keen.
Aber diese Highlights aus den Premier League Videos kann man sich gut mal angucken, da sind einige echt gold dabei. Also Nicholas Jackson ist auch richtig gut, Anja Farke ist super.
Die sind echt gut.
Ich sehe schon, dann muss ich mal gucken, ob ich den Link dazu finde und noch in die Show notes packe. Nicholas Jackson wurde ja von Christian Arbeit bei Union als Nicolas Jackson bei seiner Einwechslung bezeichnet. Und das ist natürlich näher wahrscheinlich an der richtigen Aussprache. Aber da ist mir erst mal aufgefallen, dass ich bei diesem Namen gar nicht drüber nachgedacht hab, dass ich den die ganze Zeit falsch ausspreche. Und wenn es einem ja auch bei anderen Namen die ganze Zeit um die Ohren gehauen wird, was da auch ehrlich gesagt allen egal hat, hat sich niemand gemeldet. Kommt aus der Premier League, der wird ja schon englisch ausgesprochen werden. Kevin Schade, stark. Jetzt will ich ihn noch mehr bei der WM mit dabei haben. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Wir blicken nochmal nach Frankreich, Jakob. Und da wolltest du nochmal kurz über ein paar interessante Wintertransfers sprechen.
Wen gibt es denn da so?
Genau. Ich habe zwei Unterthemen und ein Bonusthema. Und wir gehen von negativ zu positiv. Und negativ ist mir auf jeden Fall aufgefallen, dass Frankreich ja schon seit Jahren jetzt als Ausbildungsland gilt. Und es klar ist, okay, es werden wahnsinnig viele super junge Spieler schon früh reingeworfen, die dann auch wirklich riesiges Potenzial mitbringen. Und die gehen dann für viel Geld in andere Ligen. Jetzt nimmt es allerdings, finde ich, überhand, dass sie wirklich extrem früh wechseln. Und das hat man jetzt auch diesen Winter gesehen. Wir hatten es gerade bei Marseille schon mit Rubinho Vaz und Bacolar, die beide mit 18 jetzt schon weggegangen sind. Bei Monaco ist George Ilikena für 30 Millionen nach Saudi-Arabien gewechselt. Der war auch lange noch kein Stammspieler, hat zwei Saison-Tore gemacht in dieser Saison. Natürlich ist es logisch, dass der Verein dann sagt, okay, machen wir, weil wenn der sich jetzt verletzt oder sich gar nicht durchsetzt in den nächsten Jahren, werden sie nicht 30 Millionen für den bekommen. 30 Millionen gab es auch für Stadtrännen, für Kada Meite, ziemlich ähnlicher Fall wie George Ilekena. Auch er hat erst fünf Tore im Profibereich gemacht in dieser Saison, gut 500 Minuten gespielt bei Stadtrännen. Trotzdem hat Al Hilal 30 Millionen auf den Tisch gelegt. Angé hat einen von den starken Stürmern, über die wir auch schon mal gesprochen hatten, in dieser Saison verkauft, an Fenerbahce. Also auch gar nicht so die typischen Ligen, in die die Spieler sonst gewechselt sind. Also nicht unbedingt England, Deutschland, sondern dann auch die Türkei und Saudi-Arabien. Auch da kriegt Angé im Gesamtpaket wohl so 30 Millionen. Das ist aber eine Laie mit Kaufpflicht. Und der krasseste Fall ist aber vielleicht beim FC Messe, die ja unten drin stehen und einen 17-jährigen Stürmer für 12 Millionen an Aston Villa verkauft haben, Brian Maddow, der 157 Minuten im Profibereich gespielt hat in seiner ganzen Karriere. Kein Tor gemacht hat in dieser Saison, fünf Mal als Joker gekommen ist. Und ja, der sollte eigentlich bei Metz jetzt in der Rückrunde, so wie ich das gehört habe, eine größere Rolle spielen, zumindest immer von der Bank kommen. Bei Aston Villa wird er sicherlich aber auch mehr Spielzeit sammeln können jetzt. Da bin ich ganz optimistisch.
Gut, er steht hier erstmal, dass er in die U21 von Aston Villa gewechselt ist, also aber dafür 12 Millionen Euro. Ist ja ehrlicherweise immer ein Anzeichen dafür, dass ein Markt dann überkauft ist, wenn eben so was passiert, muss man tatsächlich sagen.
Ja, aber ihm muss man fairerweise natürlich sagen, dass er Engländer ist, dementsprechend da dann auch dieser Homegrown-Faktor sicherlich auch noch eine Rolle gespielt hat zusätzlich dazu.
Klar.
Aber ja, es sind auf jeden Fall viele gegangen. Und dann der größte Transfer ist ja Jeremie Jacquet, der allerdings ja jetzt noch da bleiben wird bei Startrennen. Im Gesamtpaket glaube ich fast 70 Millionen. Das ist schon ein echt talentierter Innenverteidiger und der bringt auch alles mit. Aber ja, er spielt halt auch nur bei Startrennen und die sind jetzt auch nicht die absoluten Überflieger. Es ist schon viel Geld.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, vor allen Dingen aus Liverpools Sicht. Also klar, das ist auch wieder nur ein Bilanzthema, aber die haben genau zwei gesunde Innenverteidiger und keinen gesunden Rechtsverteidiger. Und jetzt holen sie jemanden für den Sommer. Im letzten Sommer haben sie 60 Millionen.
Ich dachte auch, ich gucke nicht richtig.
Das macht keinen Sinn. Im letzten Sommer bieten sie 60 Millionen für Marc Gay, aber nicht 20 Millionen im Winter. I don't get it. Also wenn es dein Wunschspieler ist. Also klar, das hängt hundertprozentig auch mit PSA zusammen. Bei Essen will er übrigens auch. Das ist auch die Erklärung für den Deal. Die haben halt noch ein bisschen was auf der hohen Kante, was sie sich haben leisten können. Dafür kriegst du aber niemanden, der ernsthaft hilft. Also machen sie perspektivisch. Die haben ja auch in den Laien derart rumgebaut, um einfach links und rechts 2,50 Mark zu sparen, ohne dass sie davon überzeugt sind. Und Harvey Elliott ist ja wahrscheinlich so das größte Opfer von… Auch das verstehe ich by the way nicht, warum Liverpool die Laie nicht terminiert, weil der spielt nicht, weil es ansonsten eine Kaufverpflichtung gibt. Also die dosieren die Minuten sehr genau, weil sie sich den gar nicht leisten können. Und jetzt ist der da im Kader, trainiert mit, spielt aber nie, ist manchmal im Spieltags-Kader, damit er nicht komplett unzufrieden ist. Und Liverpool hat es einfach vergessen, die Laie zu terminieren. Aber ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, was da dahinter steckt. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Lieber spielt er bei Liverpool nicht und trainiert aber da, als dass man ihn bei Esten Willa einfach versauern lässt. Also diese Winterperiode, so gut die Sommerperiode war von Liverpool, die checke ich nicht. Gar nicht.
Ja, und dann haben wir ja noch ein Bonusthema.
Genau, kurz das Bonusthema. Nur einmal, wir müssen natürlich einmal nach Straßburg gucken, denn da haben wir ja über Absurditäten im Multiclub Ownership schon in der letzten Folge auch gesprochen. Und Überraschung, Überraschung, sie haben jetzt zwei Ligen terminiert von Chelsea mit Kendry Paez, der tatsächlich auch keine Rolle gespielt hat. Aber auch Mamadou Sarr ist zurück zu Chelsea. Der, man muss es sagen, der zweite Kapitän bei Straßburg auch war. Also hinter Emega, der ja auch keine Rolle mehr spielt und ja auch im Sommer zu Chelsea geht. Und da ist jetzt also das nächste riesige Stück aus der Straßburg-Mannschaft rausgerissen worden. Aber dafür haben sie auch Aaron Anselmino gekriegt, den Chelsea ja unbedingt wieder brauchte, angeblich von Dortmund.
War ein sehr wichtiges Spiel damals. Ja, ein sehr wichtiges Spiel damals.
Da aufgeschlagen ist und dann haben sie auch noch David Dattrow-Fofana geholt, der jetzt glaube ich in den letzten fünf, sechs Transferperioden zum fünften Mal an einen unterschiedlichen Verein verdienen wird von Chelsea. Also auch, der war ja auch mal bei Union, meine ich. Und ja, wird auch hin und her geschoben wie Ware und dann aber, um auf einen positiven Punkt zu enden, es gibt auch ein paar Transfers, die durchaus spannend sind und das sind jetzt Zugänge, denn da spreche ich vielleicht nicht unbedingt um Buna Saar, der zu Mest gegangen ist von den Bayern, aber zum einen natürlich Giro Immobile, immer noch ein cooler Name, der jetzt bei Paris FC spielt in der Rückrunde, auch gestern im Pokal sein Debüt gefeiert hat, da er auch schon eine gute Chance hatte, die er aber vergeben hat. Ich bin gespannt, jetzt bei Bologna hat er ja nicht unbedingt Bäume ausgerissen, aber vielleicht ist er so ein bisschen der Spieler, der bei Paris auch fehlt, denn die Zulieferung ist eigentlich ganz gut, finde ich, und da fehlte jemand auf der Stürmerposition. Dann Eli Wahi, der ja von Frankfurt ausgeliehen ist, ist richtig gut gestartet, hat drei Tore in vier Spielen gemacht bei Nizza.
Das sehen es GD-Fans auch gern.
Genau, da einen richtig guten Effekt gehabt. Dann hat man mit Rémi Cabella und Gaëtan Perrin noch zwei Urgesteine der Liga, die jetzt zurückgekommen sind. Perrin hat bei Auxerre in der letzten Saison auch 20 Scorer gesammelt, ist jetzt bei Lille. Cabella ist bei Nantes, die ja krass abstiegsgefährdet sind. Der war früher auch bei Montpellier, Marseille, Saint-Etienne, Lille, zwischendurch auch mal in Newcastle. Und dann aber mein persönlicher Favorite ist Alain Saint-Maximin, der bei Lens aufgeschlagen hat. Der war ja nicht so glücklich in Mexiko, soll da ja auch rassistisch beleidigt worden sein und so. Und der ist erst 28, da war ich echt ein bisschen überrascht. Und bei Lens hat man ja auch gute Erfahrungen gemacht, jetzt im Sommer mit Rückkehrern. Also Thauvin hat ja wahnsinnig gut eingeschlagen, ist einer der besten Spieler der Liga. Auch Odson Edouard funktioniert richtig gut. Und ich freue mich total, es am Maximale jetzt bei Lens zu sehen. Er hat gestern sein Debüt gefeiert im Pokal nach Einwechslung. Und da freue ich mich echt drauf. Denn wenn man sich an seine gute Newcastle-Zeit erinnert, kann das schon jetzt nochmal ein echter Unterschiedsspieler sein für Lens.
Gut nennst du die, okay.
Teilweise schon, oder?
Nein, das ist einfach der hetozentrische Spieler der Premier League-Geschichte, aber das war nicht schlecht.
Nur mal ganz kurz, um es reinzuwerfen. Seit seiner Newcastle-Zeit zu 23, Al-Hali, Fenerbahce, Mexiko mit CF America. So kann eine Fußballer-Karriere auch weitergehen. Wo hat das alles gelernt? Bei Hannover 96. Ja, so schaut es nämlich aus. Grüße an Ansgar, falls er das hier hört. Okay, also Ligue 1 war wild in diesem Wintertransfer-Fenster. Kann man, glaube ich, so zusammenfassen. Wild war auch so einiges, was Real mal wieder geliefert hat. Alex, wir haben ja die großen Probleme bei Real in der letzten Sendung schon besprochen. Aber jetzt gab es auch quasi in jüngerer Vergangenheit wieder Berichtenswerte. Was ist los bei Madrid?
Ja, ich würde gerne auch über Transfers hier sprechen, aber in La Liga wird ja nichts gekauft. Da hat ja keiner Geld außer Atletico. Wir hatten es ja. Von daher müssen wir sportlich werden, weil bei Real Madrid ja ein Aufreger-Spiel war. Also es war wirklich das Aufreger-Spiel dieses Spieltags und einer der Kontroversen, vielleicht sogar wirklich mit Blick auf die komplette Liga-Saison, wie, in welcher Art und Weise Real Madrid da sein Spiel wieder gewonnen hat. La Liga-Kenner sagen, naja, alles wie immer, alles wie gewohnt. Aber poch, also man musste schon mit dem armen Rallo, das ja alles gegeben hat, das ein sehr gutes Spiel gemacht hat, gegen ein Real, das bodenlos aussah. Also man muss es wirklich so ansprechen. Die spielen nicht wie eine Mannschaft Fußball, die spielen auch nicht wie ein Titel-Anwärter-Fußball, sondern das ist zusammenhanglos, das ist teilweise Larifari. Und das kleine RAIO, St. Pauli Spanien, hat im Bernabéu wirklich guten Fußball gespielt. Dann gab es eine rote Karte, eine berechtigte rote gewesen, muss man sagen, hier schön gestempelt, Stollen voraus, also keine Schiri-Kontroverse in dem Punkt. Aber dann ging es natürlich bergab für RAIO, mit 10 Mann logischerweise. Dann kam die Schlussphase von Real Madrid, hier Powerplay. Man kennt es ja aus der Champions League vor zwei Jahren gegen die PSG, Suncities dieser Welt. Das gründen sie auch sehr, sehr gut. Aber was sie halt dann machen, sie ziehen halt alle Register, um irgendwie ihr Tor zu schießen. Und meistens in der Saison ist ihr Tor halt der Elfmeter. Wir hatten vorhin eine Statistik bei irgendeinem Spieler, ich habe vergessen, wie er hieß. Die Hälfte der Tore bei Elfmeter, das kann man bei Mbappé, glaube ich, so auch nachlesen. Und ja, das Geschmäckle war eben, sie haben alles probiert, um irgendwie ihren Elfmeter zu bekommen. Und wenn man das gesehen hat, da muss man echt sagen, das war, poch, shameless Wahnsinn. Vier Schwalben nur in der zweiten Halbzeit, und man muss es Schwalben nennen, Flops, Schwalben, hinschmeißen, sobald ein Gegend in deiner Nähe ist und dich berühren könnte, schmeißen sie sich hin und sie bekommen halt nie eine gelbe Karte dafür und deswegen machen sie es immer weiter. Also es ist tatsächlich systematisches Schinden von Elfmetern, Vinicius einmal, zweimal Mbappé selbst, mit einem, mit einer Schraube, wo du, Alter, also wenn du das siehst, Brahim Dias hat es einmal probiert. Es gab nicht den Elfmeter, aber es gab auch nie eine gelbe, also machen sie es weiter. Und dann gab es neun Minuten Nachspielzeit, woher die kamen, weiß kein Mensch. Und dann gab es in der acht Minuten Nachspielzeit dann doch endlich den Elfmeter bei, auch einem. Den kannst du pfeifen, aber musst du ihm pfeifen, weiß ich nicht, weil der Ball auch berührt wird und natürlich macht Brahim wieder mehr draus. Also es war ein Spiel, über das ja in Spanien natürlich sehr, sehr enthusiastisch dann berichtet und gesprochen wurde im Nachhinein. Und Real Madrid hat mal wieder ein Spiel irgendwie gewonnen, aber ohne, dass sie wirklich überzeugen und eben mit Hilfe der verschiedenen Kräfte, die es so gibt, unter anderem der Anziehungskraft.
Und wenn wir jetzt Nils hier hätten vom Tiki Taka Podcast, der ja eher die Real-Sicht der Dinge vertritt, würde der das auch so darstellen?
Das kann man sehr schön in der Folge am Montag nachhören, übrigens Max, als wir darüber gesprochen haben. Und er hat auch gesagt, ja, die Schwalben, das ist schon too much des Guten oder der Schlechten in dem Fall. Also man weiß ja, in Spanien, da wird immer Schauspielerei begangen und Zeitspiel, das gehört dazu zur Kultur in Spanien, leider. Aber jetzt hat es Real Madrid wirklich, wirklich übertrieben. Also es waren allein vier Schwalben, systematisches Schinden. Und wenn das nicht bestraft wird, und das ist ja das Thema, das eigentlich oben drüber steht oder das eigentliche Kernthema, wenn du das nicht bestrafst und sanktionierst, was machst du denn? Du förderst es. Es führt dazu, dass Spieler, egal von welchem Verein, egal in welchem Spiel, sich natürlich erst recht hinschmeißen, schinden, Schauspielern sich das Gesicht halten, wenn sie an der Schulter getroffen werden, wenn sie irgendwo berührt werden, unten, es gibt einen Kontakt, schmeißen sich hin, wollen ihren Elfmeter. Das führt dir dazu, dass das immer mehr betrieben wird von egal welchen Spielern, weil du es nicht sanktionierst, weil du Schauspielerei nicht eindämmst. Das gab es auch im Baskendurby zwischen Real Sociedad und Athletic Bilbao, wo der eine Spieler den anderen etwas gegen die Schulter schubst, der andere sagt, geh weg, lass mich in Ruhe, berührt den hier irgendwo, und der schmeißt sich hin und hält sich natürlich das Gesicht, und der Spieler kriegt die rote Karte für nichts, ein absoluter Nichts. Nichts war das. Und er war, bleibt stumm. So, und das förderst du eben, Schauspielerei, Schwalben, Übertreiben, Schinden, weil du es nicht eindämmst, weil du es nicht sanktionierst durch gelbe Karten. Und das steht über allem. Und Real Madrid, dass die so natürlich dann zum Erfolg gekommen sind, und die haben es halt eben wirklich übertrieben, ist ja nicht nur geschmäckle, sondern wirklich sehr, sehr unschön gewesen.
Ich habe eine Frage noch an dich, Alex. Gibt's du inzwischen im Nürnberger Raum immer die Hand her nach den Spielen? Oder hat sich da nichts verbessert?
Okay, okay. Selbstverständlich mache ich das immer, weil mir wurde ja gesagt, ich muss das machen. Ja, gut.
Ja, dann können wir mal wissen, weil das klang schon wieder danach, als würdest du da persönliche Dinge in Richtung Schiedsrichter loswerden wollen.
Also es gab in letzter Zeit tatsächlich keinen Grund, einen Handschlag zu verweigern oder dem aus… also nicht verweigern.
Also hast du oft genug gewonnen in der Vergangenheit.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich wurde selten genug beschissen von den Schiedsrichtern. Nee, es gab eigentlich keine Vorkommnisse jeglicher negativer Art. Aber meine Spieler schinden auch zu wenig Elfmeter. Vielleicht sollte ich ihnen auch das beibringen. für mir selbst.
Alex, aufhören jetzt. Wir wollen nicht wieder… also an alle diejenigen, die das jetzt nicht verstanden haben, ihr hört zu wenig Ligatour, da habt ihr ein legendäres Segment verpasst. Ist schon ein paar Wochen her oder ein paar Monate. Sogar schon, aber ja.
Lass es hier bald gewinnen.
Ich glaube, wir können froh sein, wenn Alex dem lokalen Schiedsrichter-Chef nicht anfängt, Geld zu zahlen, oder?
Oh, okay, okay.
Die Black Knight Football Group, die würden da im Verein einsteigen, weißt du Bescheid.
Aber wirklich, ich würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn irgendwo ein Papagei im Hintergrund auftaucht und der eine Hass-Terade auf Real Madrid anfängt zu singen. Oder ich weiß nicht, wer jetzt eure direkten Konkurrenten bei euch im Nürnberger Raum sind. Das ist dann wahrscheinlich…
Für zu weit.
Schiedsrichter.
Vestenbachs-Gebäude.
Genau. Für zu weit. Also ich merke schon, das Schiedsrichter-Thema mache ich so schnell hier nicht mehr auf, wenn Uli zu kass ist.
Das fühlt sich nicht so gut an.
Du warst einfach einmal zu ehrlich, Alex. Und das wird halt einfach bestraft. Das könnte Real Madrid halt nicht passieren.
Das stimmt.
Oh, das gibt die. Viel Spaß.
Ja, ach, lustigerweise hören die entsprechenden Bubbles, hören die Ligatour nicht. Also deswegen, hier kannst du auch einfach sagen, ja, Leo Messi ist halt klar besser als Cristiano Ronaldo. Haut alle ab, ihr Pfeifen.
Und das an seinem Geburtstag.
Und das wird nicht passieren. Wer ist es, Leo Messi oder Cristiano Ronaldo? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hoffe, das stimmt. Ich habe das gerade nur beim Überfliegen gesehen, dass der heute 41 war.
Das wäre jetzt wirklich schlimm, wenn wir eben… Na gut.
Na gut. Dann verlassen wir es dabei.
Ein Punkt, kurz überlegt, ob ich nochmal nachlege.
Aber ich glaube, das war genug Zunder für diese Folge. Wir haben noch ein Thema in der Serie A offen. Christian, was hast du uns mitgebratzt? Muss jetzt unterhaltsam sein? Ja, vielleicht wird es unterhaltsam, hoffentlich. Ja, schauen wir uns kurz mal Udinese an von Kosta Runjaic, die wirklich sehr, sehr gut dastehen. Gerade auch aktuell haben die Roma geschlagen. Jetzt an diesem Spieltag 1 zu 0. Sie haben gleich viele Punkte wie Lazio. Sie sind Punkt gleich 8 oder 9. Auch nur wenige Punkte von Atalanta weg. Also wenn wir uns ja erinnern, vielleicht die letzten Jahre, da war Udinese auch immer wieder dann Richtung Abstiegsstrudeln mit dabei. Und das Thema ist jetzt schon durch. Die haben, glaube ich, was sagen sie, 15 Punkte vorsprungen und haben wirklich nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun. Also wieder sehr, sehr solide. Im Prinzip macht Udinese weiterhin das, was sie in den Jahren davor schon gemacht haben, in dem sie eben sehr solide und gut waren. Weiterhin eine extrem körperlich starke Mannschaft. Also Gasperini hat es jetzt eben auch. Ich meine, die Roma ist jetzt auch nicht unkörperlich. Aber er hat gemeint, Udinese hat uns einfach im physischen Bereich, waren sie uns überlegen. Also das ist weiter das Grundmotiv, dass sie fahren. Picken wir uns zwei, drei Spieler raus, glaube ich, weil man Udinese ja nicht immer auf dem Schirm hat. Das Siegtor gerade gegen die Roma hat Jürgen Ekelenkamp geschossen. Vielleicht erinnert sich noch ein paar. Hertha BSC-Vergangenheit, das ist einer, der da gut funktioniert. Vielleicht der größte Name vom Namen her. Sie haben Niccolò Zaniolo zurückgeholt von Galatasaray. Zaniolo ist in den letzten Jahren so ein bisschen rumgegeistert, irgendwo nie wieder das Niveau gefunden, dass er da in jungen Jahren bei der Roma hatte. Auch klar hat man ja auch schon, gibt es außerfußballerische Themen, aber auch zwei Kreuzbandrisse. Also muss man auch mit drin halten. Aber jetzt scheint er, er kam von Galatasaray und scheint bei Udinese wirklich den Rhythmus gefunden haben. Mehrere Tore schon, ganz entscheidend. Jetzt einen kleinen Eingriff am Knie gehabt, aber anscheinend nichts Schlimmeres. Ich glaube, ich kann in zwei, drei Wochen schon wieder mit dabei sein. Also Zaniolo funktioniert richtig gut, für ihn logisch sehr gut und auch für Udinese. Keenan Davis, mal schauen, ob der Uli noch was sagt. Ich glaube, von Aston Villa kam der vor zwei oder drei Jahren. Also physisch sehr physisch starker Neuner, funktioniert richtig gut, trifft. Da gab es zuletzt auch mehrere Transfergerüchte, da waren auch größere dran. Hatte so ein bisschen nur, um eine Idee zu bekommen, was das für ein Spielertyp ist, hat jetzt so ein, zwei Mal einen Lukaku-Stempel bekommen. Also wirklich einer, der physisch einfach wahnsinnig viel mitbringt und eben da perfekt da vorne mit reinpasst. Und damit wir einen Jakob auch mit reinholen, Arthur Atta, ex Mets, den hat Udinese von Mets geholt. Der war früher, glaube ich, auch so im Umfeld der französischen UN-Nationalmannschaften, 23. Der macht wirklich den nächsten Schritt. Der war letztes Jahr schon sehr vielversprechend, ist jetzt auch, hat schon mehrere Tore geschossen und sehr auffällig einfach einer. Und damit sind wir wieder beim Punkt. Bei Udinese kommt es jetzt anscheinend wieder in die Richtung. Das war ja das Udinese von früher, sehr gutes Scouting, immer wieder mal Leute holen, die anderen noch nicht auf dem Schirm haben, dann später logischerweise damit Geld verdienen. Habe jetzt auch mir ein bisschen angeschaut, das ist wirklich faszinierend. Also das Scouting scheint wieder zu greifen. Udinese hat zum Beispiel auch den Kapitän, bitte leg mich nicht auf den Namen fest, den Kapitän der französischen U19-Nationalmannschaften. Zwei Achterjahrgang. Also auch solche ganz junge Leute, die sind einfach schon da, die holen sie, haben jetzt auch im Winter ganz interessante jungen serbischen Innenverteidiger geholt. Den wollte der Inter, den wollten viele in Europa. Aber er kam dann zu Dinesse, weil er da jetzt wahrscheinlich Spielpraxis kriegt. Also, dass Dinesse Scout den greift wieder. Und dementsprechend macht da Rounia Hatsch logisch einen sehr, sehr guten Job. Sehr schön Max, danke, dass du das noch kurz aufmachst. Und das alles vor dem Hintergrund, um auch nochmal die Brücke zu Jakob zu schlagen, dass sie im Sommer nicht nur Thauvin abgegeben haben, sondern auch Lorenzo Lucca. Also der neun oder letzte Saison, der ja wirklich sehr wichtig war. Also im Prinzip haben sie ja ein komplettes Sturmbuhr, das sie offensiv getragen hat, abgegeben. Sind jetzt aber besser.
Hab ich dich zu dem noch was fragen, zu Lucca? Weil der ist ja in Nottingham. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was ich machen soll mit dem.
Da bist du nicht allein, Uli. Also, Lucca noch ganz kurz. Er hat letztes Jahr gut funktioniert, junger Mann. Den hat er Napoli geholt für viel Geld. Da reden wir, glaube ich, hoch 20 oder über 30. Und bei Napoli und Conte, das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Also wir kennen ja die Geschichte von Napoli, die ungefähr alle Krankenhäuser in und um Neapel mit Spielern belegen. Also in Neapel, wenn du diese Saison mal Spielzeit hättest kriegen können, dann jetzt. Und obwohl sie so viele Verletzte hatten, hat Lucca und der Conte zuletzt sogar gar keine Rolle mehr gespielt. Also das wurde gar nichts. Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch ein paar Szenen auch in der Champions League. Da waren ein paar technische Fehler auch mit dabei, wo du sagst, ich weiß nicht. Also der hat sicher den Schritt, glaube ich, der war groß. Ich meine, wenn du von Udine, wo du halt in einem kleinen Biotop bist, wo dir auch medial nicht viel passieren kannst, wenn du dann als Junge nach Neapel kommst zum Meister, große Aufmerksamkeit, viel Geld für dich bezahlt. Der Schritt war, glaube ich, zu groß, kann man jetzt sagen. Deswegen überrascht es mich auch, dass der in der Premier League jetzt einen Abnehmer gefunden hat. Überraschung, weißt du Uli, logisch, er bringt halt eine Physis mit. Das ist logischerweise, davon lebt er. Aber ganz schwierig, ich weiß nicht. Bin sehr gespannt, wie viel er jetzt da spielt. Weil wie gesagt, Conte hat den wirklich nicht mehr gesehen. Conte hat teilweise 17-jährige Nachwuchsspieler vor ihnen in der Schlussphase gebracht, wenn sie in Rückstand waren. Und er war fit. Also, ja, deswegen, das, glaube ich, wird jetzt auch erst mal die nächsten Wochen noch ein Mysterium sein, bin ich mal gespannt. Aber bei dem ist viel im Kopf. Der Schritt nach Neapel, glaube ich, war zu groß für ihn, genau. Und ist das für dich ein Thema, dass wir mit Kosta Runjaic, ja, da auch einen uns bekannten Trainer, deswegen wollte ich sie auch mal mitbringen, ja. Also, für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, Darmstadt Duisburg, Lautern 60 und dann eben über Auslandsstationen in Stettin und Warschau dann eben bei Udinese gelandet. Ja, also, wie gesagt, ist er einer, der auch in Italien logisch jetzt nicht groß im Fokus steht. Vielleicht zur Erinnerung nochmal, vor ihm war Fabio Cannavaro Trainer bei Udinese. Also, da haben sie so den großen Namen halt gesucht und dann kam eben Ronjaic. Und ja, ich glaube, alle, die Ronjaic auch aus Deutschland kennen, ist glaube ich jetzt nicht unbedingt einer, der groß im Mittelpunkt steht oder auch das Scheinwerferlicht auf sich zieht. Aber wenn man jetzt die Saison eben anschaut, das ist halt schon stark. Wenn du mit Lazio mitspielst, wenn du nur wenige Punkte dahinter Atalanta bist und eigentlich vom Prinzip her sogar ein bisschen nach oben Richtung europäische Plätze schiedeln kannst und im Sommer Thauvin und Luka verloren hast, dann würde ich sagen, spricht das sehr für die ruhige Art von Ronjaic. Wie gesagt, auch in Italien nicht groß auf dem Radar, aber macht seinen Job und führt eben genau diesen Weg fort. Körperlich unangenehm, stark, physisch. Und hat zuletzt eben nicht nur die Roma, hat auch Napoli geschlagen. Also ja, definitiv eine richtig, richtig gute Saison von Uli Nese und von Ronjaic. So, und Jakob hat die letzte Frage dieser Sendung.
Ich wollte nur kurz den Namen nachtragen des französischen Nationalmannschaftskapitäns. Das ist Abdullai Kamara.
Ja, danke.
Der kam der letzten Sommer aus Montpellier. 1,2 Millionen für den Kapitän von der französischen UNationalmannschaft. Das ist schon ein ganz netter Deal auf jeden Fall.
Würde ich auch mal sagen, genau, auf dem Papier erst mal. Jetzt schauen wir mal als ein junger Mann, wie sich das entwickelt. Aber das eben nur als Beispiel, dass eben genau das Kernstück von Dinesse, das die ja seit über, kann man sagen, ein, zwei Jahrzehnte stark gemacht hat. Da könnte man jetzt ein ganzes Thema aufmachen, wer alles durch die Dinesse-Schule gegangen ist. Und das war vielleicht die letzten ein, zwei Jahre, ist da so ein bisschen Knick reingekommen. Und jetzt scheint es wieder auf einem guten Weg zu sein, dass sie da wirklich auch dieses Scouting, dass es wieder greift. Und so schnell kann es gehen. Vorhin sag ich noch, französische Liga, französischer Markt komplett überkauft und begründet das mit irgendwelchen 30-Millionen-Transfers von 17-Jährigen nach Saudi-Arabien. Und jetzt sehen wir, na ganz so schlimm überkauft kann er ja noch nicht sein, wenn du die Kamera noch holen kannst. Naja, so schnell geht es auch im Rasenfunk. Ihr vier, das war wie immer eine sehr, sehr schöne Sendung. Danke, dass ihr euch auch die Zeit dafür genommen habt. Wurde ja heute etwas länger. Herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel, Alex Truica, Jakob Haffke und Christian Bernhard. Vielen, vielen Dank euch allen. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, denn ihr wisst ja, ihr habt diese Sendung hier möglich gemacht. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbungsponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Paul, bei Sebastian, Sebi Kreisig, bei Lothar, bei Sebastian und bei QQ-Joba. Vielen Dank für euren Support. Wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge, dann geht sehr gerne auf mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Da könnt ihr es loswerden. Und empfehlt doch diese Sendung sehr, sehr gerne weiter. Jetzt nicht unbedingt an Cristiano Ronaldo Fanboys. Das braucht dann doch nicht. Aber allen anderen sei diese Folge hier sehr ans Herz gelegt. In diesem Sinne, bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.